all right and we are live the last word
with lord cognito ibontes thai guy
travis fresh on that thursday evening
campfire good to be back gentlemen good
to be back i missed you guys and take
care of some business but uh we got a
cool guest before we get into that let's
start off my manny bontes the cheetah
how are we doing sir
um
stupid moment happened while while you
were gone this was actually a word no it
was uh doing some work on the house was
a ladder incident which i'm recovering
um
i'm lucky i'll be honest i'm lucky it's
yeah like i'm like i'm lucky because it
could have been worse anything related
to a ladder could be worse
so i've been trying to go around all of
our windows because the house is
solder and like the caulk and stuff and
everything is like cracking so i've been
trying to like seal up everything just
to help because it's on thousand degrees
in the state right now yeah texas i feel
for y'all so i've been trying to go
around and do that and i was working on
the front and like we have a bonus room
over the garage but there's a couple
windows up there well i had the ladder
up there a couple days before and just
like the frame of the window i could
just like slide a screwdriver almost a
wrench in there it's so uselessly like
busted out it
so i finally got some like spray foam
insulation to at least put in there to
start
basically what had happened was
i had the ladder against the house but i
just
didn't think didn't have it tilted quite
enough so when i got up to the window
it slid down the house and i rode the
ladder down no but there's a garage
below it
sure the garage was open so once the we
got to the garage level i wrote it for
about six seven how tall is a garage
eight feet free fall
just straight down and smash the ground
so
i'm okay like i don't know if i like you
know fractured a toe or something like
that you can't do [ __ ] about a toe so
there's nothing you can do for a toe
that's how it goes but the inside of my
knee hit the ground like
really hard
it's was really swollen it was like it
was kind of hard to straighten it out
and it's been it's progressively been
getting better basically so it's like i
didn't get x-rays it's been no i don't
think so it's like because it's been
at this point it's just like because
when i broke my leg when i was like 16
if you ever do something bad like that
when you stand up and the blood like
flows into that area that's injured and
swells it hurts like hell so the same
thing kind of was happening here but i
think it was just a big bruise around a
lot of a joint so it's been getting
progressively better by the day but
yeah so that was like one of those
moments where i'm like
that wasn't fun
and your last life flashed before before
no you want to know the bad thing is it
didn't flash it was a slow slide when it
went down the side of the house so it
was slow motion it was like
i was like
there's nothing i could do i'm just
sitting there like well
and then you just
so that's what i say to travis i said he
needs to be thankful for the calves he
has the legs
to protect it my eye wouldn't i would
have broke my leg with
see that's what good
[Laughter]
that would have just shattered through
your entire skeleton just everything's
over i'm glad all jokes
uh but yeah i mean outside of that one
um
obviously been playing a fair amount of
destiny 2 between
finishing up iron banner and now in
solstice which we'll talk about both of
those um kind of in separate pieces
and then just trying to there's a game
that i got called eldest souls a while
ago and i played do you know what i'm
talking about travis it's like a little
basically 2d kind of isometric boss rush
thing and i played like
four or five of the bosses but i didn't
get to all of them and i kind of got to
a point was like right now i gotta
wander around find somebody just kind of
fell off of it or something i kind of
picked it back up and i downed one of
the bosses and now i'm working on no i
downed
two of the bosses and now i literally
just have to figure out where like the
last two are and i can kind of check
that box for another indie this year so
i've just been having fun with little
games after elden ring i want little
stuff right now because horizon's my
next big one that's where i eventually
got to go back so that's what i've been
up to um yeah
falling ladder story could have been
much worse
um
a little bit of coin not a little bit of
massive coincidence
um
my dad is gonna turn 80 this year and my
mom was very pissed at my dad for this
because while she was gone he was on a
ladder changing a smoke detector in
their house he actually fell and cracked
five ribs oh my god
his family did my girlfriend's dad fell
off a ladder like last week now that you
mentioned this he broke his he broke his
uh clavicle he's his collarbone oh
i just completely forgot about that
until he's sorry
one piece of advice have two people
around a ladder for one
two-person job that's the big thing do
it do it don't be like oh i'm just gonna
go knock this stuff out get that other
person in there yeah better idea stay
away from ladders
yeah can you turn yourself up just a
little bit yes travis a little low
travel's a little low oh
i can turn myself okay to me i didn't
say on i said up thank you very much i
head up to you sick monster
well what have you been up to you
sickness
is that is that loud enough i turned my
gain up yeah you're good you're better
now you're good you're good
i
have
finished xenoblade chronicles 3. it is
done
it is done i am most of the way through
writing the review i'm gonna put the
finishing touches on the review tonight
do edits tomorrow do my vo and
annotations over the weekend and then be
ready for it to go live on tuesday
because the video team needs it by
monday
so falls when does your piece do
it's due well i have to turn it in
tomorrow morning so i have to finish it
tonight but uh the uh it goes live on
tuesday morning um because the video
team needs monday to actually work on it
um
the community
will understand whatever score you're
going to give it
i don't claim to judge a
psychopathic cluster of minds uh i i
will tell you this
it is
it is very uh troubling that i did a
preview like two weeks ago and in it my
preview was overwhelmingly positive
however i made the fatal error of
mispronouncing a single word
uh i i i was supposed to say uroboros
and i accidentally said eros burroughs
pretty s simple mistake it's just the
slip of the tongue
however i have been flamed on reddit and
people have dm me on twitter and
basically claim that i'm a [ __ ] because
i
uh
added an s on accident to a single word
so this is a this is a community that as
you know is extremely forgiving and
understanding and rational
and so i'm sure that whatever review
score i give or whatever i send my
review they will take it with grace and
dignity and uh it'll it'll all work out
well so wow xenoblade communities is out
and he has got
i'm gonna guess it's gonna be an eight
just because
i feel like
that's that's probably where it should
land i feel like xenoblade's like a
really enjoyed franchise but i feel like
travis is a fair reviewer
so it's like i don't know if i see that
thing as a masterpiece if nothing else i
feel like the switch might be holding it
back but i feel like it could be an
enjoyable game 150 hours that's that's
i'm gonna throw that one out there we'll
see you next week if i'm right just
random guess having no
information at all
what about you what do you mean i cannot
comment on that but uh i know
yeah
i'm saying completely
yeah exactly so we will see you next
week i also have a preview going live on
that same morning tuesday morning uh for
a roller drum which is that um
rollerblading video game you have guns
yes from
months yeah yeah so i'm doing a preview
on that that might be a an ign exclusive
i'm not sure um but yeah that'll be live
today as well so i got some things
coming i have had zero time to play
destiny because i was doing 50 hours of
xenoblade per week for three weeks uh
but i'm now done with that and so i'm
excited to get back in see what this uh
solstice event is about i completely
missed iron banner i guess i'm just
gonna have to wait until next season for
that i just didn't have it
so uh i feel like i misdodged a bullet
though because uh i was reading how yeah
how it was much
yeah [ __ ] did that all right week but
we'll get to we'll get to that but yeah
feeling pretty good over here my life
so um yeah
anyway that's me mcclunkey everyone i
didn't say
see your
cognitos
yes yes yes well first of all salute to
you guys for um holding it down you know
i'm saying last week had so much going
on and then uh salute that
everybody you know say [ __ ] ball if i
apologize brother next time next time
you know his internet apologizes it's
all good he'll be stateside next time we
get him back on so yeah we gotta get him
we'll do it right we'll do it right
right when he stayed sad yeah no worries
but the internet and then my situation
but yeah for me it's kind of in the same
boat as tribe as we're sitting so busy
and then i did make a business decision
where mentally i needed a break after i
did that iron law title and i was saying
to myself i am not jumping in there
and i see my clan in there i was like i
am not doing that and i got the hooks of
the rocket blade point in me right now
i'm actually having fun
and
i should probably
like melee combat i feel like it's like
something i should 100 be playing they
at it's like a fighting game
beats like
chinese law with some dynasty warriors
the kind of thing with amazing
spider-man type traversal with gravity
kind of the second real grappling hook i
feel like i've seen in a clip here there
very much very much sakura as a battle
royale yeah
and then what it's all right first of
all has the word i'm gonna say it's the
worst uh i've ever seen excuse that it's
clearly a pc game like this this is
not a good ui but like it's so much
intricacies to the game and it's like a
like a rock paper scissors with the way
the fighting is once you learn it and
it's really engrossing they have like
this little four guys mode right now
it's funny and it it's really good like
i'm thoroughly addicted they think that
i think that separates it for me because
i'm such a fighting game enthusiast is
that each most battle royales everyone
is the same it's just what you pick up
on on the battlefield and so on and so
forth but what makes this unique is
every character has a skill set and then
a special ultimate ability so that's
where it's like this is one little
shaolin monkey
apex plus sakura
yeah it's great but here are writers in
security
hero hero back in slash and so yeah yeah
that makes sense it's so good it's just
the way they their take on it is just
really cool i feel that wasn't like
not beta but like early access i feel
like that game had like a year or it was
that for a long time right would you say
it was called
knockout
i had to take a hiatus because of the
reviews but yeah i'm really enjoying
that game i've been playing it with some
of my friends and all that stuff yeah i
really like it
so yeah i've been doing that and then as
you guys know um as does falls you know
i've been rocking that so it's been a
fun break playing a little fall guys on
the side with the lords it's been a fun
break but just like traff this is the
week i'm coming back home i see solstice
i started watching him watch his video
you know what i'm saying trying to see
what distracts please watch that video
definitely helps out the channel yes it
helps out the channel you know what i'm
saying but look enough about me rambling
we got this great guest that's been very
patient indeed yes you may have already
got a shirt and i've heard a couple
times so let's do this welcome to the
last word episode number 207
iron banner has wrapped up for this
season and those who grinded for the
iron lord title this time had a longer
road to get their title solstice is in
full swing with some changes from last
year and bungie dropped teaser to get us
all hyped for the future of the
franchise
this week we are joined by a very cool
customer and guest he's been gaming on
both console and pc for about as long as
both have existed this man's creative
mind also started very young with many
of his formative years were spent in his
high school art teacher's classroom
up to four hours in one day i heard so
when you take a look at any piece of his
hard work you know that he wants to
respect any reference material that may
be involved but there are they are
always bleeding with his own stylings as
you look deeper into his work this man
has so many layers that even the name he
goes by on the internet has multiple
meanings so it's fitting that he really
can't
quite make up his mind or make a
decision when the time comes for it so
let's welcome a man who has lived on
both coasts but currently is in the
northwest who has a bit of a green thumb
when it comes to gardening but we're not
going to talk about that one today a
ninja turtle fan amongst many other
topics an artist who knows that pixels
really do come alive when the lights go
out and who has worked with the massive
breakdown podcast blueberries.gg and
with bungie as part of the guardian's
mental health the one
the only
irresolute how you doing sir
i'm pretty good how are you all doing
great
happy to have you here
yeah thank you thank you i'm glad to be
on
alright what's going on man so we asked
a little pregame talk beforehand you
know i mean yeah a little bit you know
but i want to talk some gaming man you
got some interesting gaming history
about those burst consoles and systems
that got you into gaming some standouts
there sir that you want to bring bring
to everyone's knowledge
i mean like it might be kind of vanilla
but it was really like the nes and the
super nes that that kind of got me
in like all the way in we had
we had all sorts of stuff in the house
when i was a kid we had like a coleco
style like hook up to the tv
yeah dude it was like the joystick that
looked very much just like the one stick
with the button and the button on the
thing and you just like like the old
school atari one
um i mean we had an atari as well and
stuff like that but it wasn't until we
got
like um
an nes with the original you know duck
hunt mario
and then started getting like the zelda
games and then final fantasy and
we we got all of them we would go to the
toys r us and look through and look at
the back of the the thing on each one
pull off the yellow tab take it to the
front
yeah yeah for real
and then
they got there with you
they got the super nintendo with the
street fighter cartridge in it at the
toys r us and we were like we have to
get this and so we got that and then
like every christmas it was like getting
more games for that and you know getting
a playstation
getting a computer like i started doing
graphic design stuff when i was pretty
young and still in high school so i
always had like a pc that could
sort of play games and so i played a lot
of different things usually at like
minimum settings but you know still got
some time in on all those things but
yeah like early days console early days
everybody remembers the 8-bit and 16-bit
stuff because it's still like persists
that stuff
persists not only as classics but as
like people make things inside those
constraints as like a genre
sort of thing now it's super cool so
i've had a good time being into games
for so long
very cool history he got some questions
for the man before we pass off oh no i
mean just when it comes to
most people obviously do the 8-bit
console the super nintendo the
playstation 1. but the fact that you've
been on pc just as long i was curious if
that helped
like get you into art as kind of access
to it or how did like do you think the
pc access actually helped the kind of
digital artistry or anything of that
nature yeah or do you think that's well
done anything for you
that's a good question i think so maybe
just because it's like i was kind of
soaked in it you know what i mean like
there was always computers in the house
or like at the schools i went to they
always had something
and
um
just having like i i legit remember one
of the very first times i ever saw art
be made with a computer and it was in a
gymnasium at sherwood forest elementary
school in winston-salem in like 1988 and
it was a dude that was like check it out
i can make this circle and then i can
change the color of the circle and then
i can erase the middle of it and then i
can make the top blue and the bottom red
and oh i made the pepsi logo and i was
like he did he made the pepsi logo how
did he do that
and mesmerized i mean i think i was like
seven or something seven or eight i was
like i was so young it was when i was in
grade school and i had we had a computer
at home but he couldn't do that like it
absolutely could not do that and then a
company we got a mario paint cartridge
and i was like i kind of do have a
computer that i can do
and so like i i did
understand all that stuff pretty early
on because there was always a little bit
of a connection to it
and then once i started actually doing
graphic stuff when i was in high school
i had to have something that could
actually
you know had a little bit of weight to
it a little bit of muscle as far as like
the processor and the ram and stuff went
and so i really could just start kind of
adding in like more and more game stuff
and going back to the because i had
always played games on pc but never like
a lot of them right i wasn't like huge
into any single pc game or anything
because i i like to do so many
of the other ones like you know old and
true with the oregon trail on the uh
yeah we'd have that at my school in like
fourth fifth grade right like that was
we had blasters number munchers right i
feel like there's a frog matching or
something yep the frog like it's a
vector drawing thing yeah and then
there was so much dude like and all that
stuff like there's actually things i
remember learning about like vector
pathing when i was a kid that i
understand now and still use when i'm
using like adobe illustrator right like
it's it's
one of those things that's just been
like a saturation effect really
oh cool
question for me
um
mario paint huh
yeah dude like with and inclu up to and
including like programming the little
music thing with it and like having it
play tunes and stuff
mario paint was amazing
beautiful
was that your first game did you first
what was your first game you made
oh
probably like street fighter alpha on
this snes i played that for like an
entire summer and they had a street
fighter alpha cabinet at
the ice rink that i used to go to like
every weekend
uh when i lived in a place called reston
virginia
yeah dude
i actually kept going to that ice
skating rink for years and years because
there was a the head of a mountain bike
trail in like the back of the parking
lot and so like is like a teenager and
then as an adult i would go there for
like other reasons it was great because
they had it they had a really good
like a solid just straight they had like
no other arcade games they had a street
fighter alpha arcade cabinet there wow
and we would play that before like the
free skate on like friday and saturday
nights and i had a copy of it on uh like
home console i had it on super nintendo
and the cartridge for that was wild it
was so huge it was like extra size they
had like more they had i think the board
inside the cartridge was bigger to like
deal with the fact that there was so
much on it but it was like
it was one of my favorite games when i
was a kid alpha classic evan absolutely
can remember that one
so
awful you know
ah yeah you're one of those
what i think it was like star fight no
street fighter i think just two on snes
is the one i remember playing
yeah that was the one i remember the
most
yeah yeah yeah absolutely huge huge huge
yeah man so then you're doing your
gaming and kind of fast forward i know
we're gonna get into the career stuff
and what you do but i wanna focus a
little bit on the destiny a little bit
you know how did that that whole
attraction start
yeah i mean
that's what it was not like i think i
mean i think like everybody kind of has
some
you know
lore to how they they got to it but like
i played halo right i won two and three
like easy i played two and three like
full co-op couch co-op with a friend
that's how i beat that man it would be
nice to do that with the new one sorry
continue
yeah go listen to please say about that
dude please go listen to uh defining
duke as they
talk about the woes of that man
i'm gonna do it right now let's play it
right now oh it's at least the full
relationship
yeah i'm trying to play on this
arbitrage
boot up my my hello
it was the thing was like i almost got
to play a test flight early but then it
was like oh you also have to have been
invited i was like fine i'll just i'll
just wait like i'll just
probably just be a little while till
they open it up to more people yeah i'll
just go away
i've got the what is it the insider
yeah
yeah it's not a better thing but i'm
awake because i want to do it the right
way but yeah so like i was
it was like 2014 right right so i'm
walking around target just i don't even
remember what i was there for it's
probably just like socks or whatever
right and
it's target what are you going to target
for so many things you can go and target
and walk out there with about 20
different things yeah target can be
trouble
sir
hold on the only reason you say target
is if you're talking down about walmart
is out there in san francisco what is
what is target what is i've only got
whole foods and then upgraded the whole
foods we don't even have these traps
that's not it's not even that's right
and san francisco is pretty against like
larger companies i know walmart's not
allowed in san francisco
they're anti-union it's crazy anyway
right yeah
it took a long time for there to be
places like that in dc too and it was
largely for the same reason but they
edged in you know over time
shout out to addicts dropping at the
chat what's up sir everything travis
says is right
um hey
guys
here we go good stuff good stuff because
i slanded halo i think now he betrayed
me
he's a jam set
continue
yeah so tarjay right and i just i saw
the display and i was just like i'll try
this out and i i started playing it and
i didn't really like it honestly like at
first just playing destiny one and i was
just like this feels weird like it's not
well i picked hunter because i thought
it looked cool
and i was like okay cool i'm gonna try
this one out and it just felt like off
to me
i know why now but at the time i was
like so confused i was like this seems
really cool like i'm into all this like
the screen with the armor and the guns
and like i want to try this
and i switched over to titan because i
was like looking at the cover i was like
this guy looks like master chief
i know that's not incredibly creative
for me to be like titans look like
spartans like a lot like a lot a lot
especially in destiny 1 they looked a
lot a lot like spartans
and i was like
i wonder if that means like it'll play
like master chief does and it kind of
did like it felt a little bit like that
bungee magic that i could remember
feeling playing
the halo games and i was like oh [ __ ] so
i was really interested i just i started
like just playing the hell of it and i
had a roommate at the time
and i was like you have to try this like
we played couch co-op together you have
to try this game
and he started playing it and i like
came downstairs the next morning and he
had stayed up all night playing and i
was like it's good isn't it like this
wasn't it and he was like it does and i
was like i'm gonna buy another xbox so
we can have two of these like
and i was living in a the place we were
living at was a shared um like art
studio rehearsal space for musicians and
we had a big projector we had a huge
projector like that was like 40 60
like
it's like tall and it was probably like
15 16 feet wide easy and it was just
like the
over top of the stage where people
rehearsed and i had just set up like i
had the console plugged into the
projector like right behind me and i was
like sitting on a little recliner i just
played yesterday one on xbox for hours
with a buddy like
you know 40 feet away in the other room
started doing raids and stuff through
that started you know finding different
community members and
um
like it just you know
fast forward i don't know however many
years it's been now time has become
like squishy in the last three years but
like ever since then like i i took a
little bit of a break at the end of d1 i
didn't do some of the stuff in rise of
iron like i just fell off before that
because there was
uh you know a lot going on inside
different groups of people that i was
playing with and a bunch of stuff came
out like you were saying before we
started like you're gonna play horizon
or maybe just that might have been a few
minutes ago
brains noodles but like
it
it was one of the games that was one of
the things that pulled me off a destiny
one it was like only stuff like final
fantasy 15 and horizon zero dawn coming
out that it was like you're getting
pulled away from this thing and i mean
that's that's a pretty good run for a
game you're talking about games earlier
like that's a
having something that can like keep you
engaged for that long without having to
just like
constantly buy new titles or everything
is like that's that's pretty good value
prop right that's that's like you're
getting a lot out of it and
now even you know you see what they're
building every
three months or so is just like
this is this is what i wanted when i
first engaged with destiny it's like
this is
everything i think
well i guess you're probably impossible
to say everything but it's a lot of
pvp
let's not talk about that
that's a that's a whole thing yeah
it is it is wild though that like people
have made the joke and continue to make
the joke like it's the best destiny's
ever been and it's like a lot of times
that's very true like they put in a lot
of effort and there's really cool stuff
for a lot of different player types like
there's always something to find that
you don't
you know jive with exactly like that
doesn't work for you and
for a lot of people maybe it's been the
way pvp has shifted
but like there's still a ton in there
that i think works for just about
everybody people keep coming back even
though they don't like pvp anyway so
like
people keep coming back that is that is
true i do also like i'm probably going
to play trials a little bit this weekend
probably like you know pain
no doubt no doubt and then uh he's he
seems to film
did you say jeff
every pvp main has the same attitude as
like
uh
i i hate it i can't stop playing it
[Laughter]
or garbage for dinner what were you
going to say yeah they'll say that it's
also just an amazing skill set rez has i
know
let's talk about that
yeah it's like your world of artistry
like your paintings and stuff you got a
full website sold a ton of them now
um how i mean obviously we talked about
you kind of getting an art i joked in
the intro where even in high school
where you get said you got later on in
high school you're spending half of your
day with your in your art teacher's
classroom so
what got you into art what were the
hooks and then kind of how has that
progressed into now doing a bunch of
destiny art so let's get the art story
so yeah i mean i've been drawn since i
was a little kid um it's funny khan
young khan you'll probably know who
lance is
yeah your art looks like kind of like my
art we should be friends and i was like
but yes
like yeah sure he's a very direct dude
and very friendly it was fun to meet him
but like he had shared that one of the
first things he ever did was like draw
ninja turtles and i remembered it made
me think of like time literally like
sitting on the floor in the house when i
was like six years old like looking at a
ninja turtle action figure and like
trying to draw it like trying to take
the reference and trying to like i
really like this thing this donatello
he's my favorite let me just oh he's a
dawn mate
dude
yeah he does
he does machines why wouldn't you like
that
ignored super into it right but like
i just remember trying to draw it and
thinking like this is like fun and
that's started like a long i must have
been doing something before that right
but i don't exactly remember and i just
remember like always putting pen on pad
and like finding whatever my parents
started getting me like pencils paper
writes sketchbooks when i was a kid in
high school they let me
they let all the students do this most
of them didn't but you could pick like
your diploma type and one of them was
you've got to do a bunch of language
credits you got to do a bunch of math
and i was like no
please thank you i what else do you have
a second option and they were like you
could do this one but most people don't
because colleges don't like that and i
was like whatever fine and it was you
could take a bunch of electives
in especially like your your junior and
senior year you could just take tons
tons of electives and i was able to take
like every one of the art classes that
were about doing like studio work so i
had like an ap art history class and an
ap art studio class and a printing class
and a graphic design class and like just
the regular art classes and so it ended
up being
in every day going even this is like
public high school this wasn't like an
arts magnet school or anything like that
this is just like herndon high school in
virginia right so it's just like
they just let me stack everything and it
was the same teacher she was just like
yes just come here stay
and eventually it even got to the point
where towards like the end of my senior
year she'd be like are you done just go
home i'm tired of you like
you're you're a lot today dude and just
a lot
today and
because it was it also was like
there were milestones in those two
because it was unlike some of them were
ap classes right they're like college
credit classes so they were like just do
this much because you're going to like
your final is going to be you're going
to present all of this at like an art
show and
she knew so long as i got that stuff
done and submitted like all this
paperwork and did everything her name
was leslie casey she was amazing she
died a couple years back she's like
she was like my favorite person in high
school and i'd learned a ton from her
and a lot of it was that she just kind
of let me like roll and like she would
give me some instruction and like nudges
and pushes and be like we have this
piece of equipment we got it over the
summer you're gonna do you want to learn
this one too and it's like yes so it's
just like a pretty rad way to do it and
then went to art school in washington dc
at an art school that went out of
business
um so you know got an associate's degree
from them
and they they were actually like for
real the story is uh the george
washington university which is a big
university in dc uh which is primarily
like a law history in medical school
like
they had an art school and they split
off and they connected with one of the
privately owned museums in the in the
city that was called the corcoran and
they made a school there and it was
mostly in the basement of the school for
a really long time and they mostly only
topped painting for like a really long
time and illustration and then when i
started going there in like 2002 they
had like a digital um program they had
graphic design and stuff so i i did that
and it was great
i mean it was kind of a weird
um kind of weird that like dc not really
like an art place so much unless you're
talking like the history museums which
they have a lot of and they have a lot
they have a lot of museums a lot of
people look like it's not
there wasn't really like an art scene or
anything and so i just did a lot of
different stuff until
um
probably only about
i think it's like five or six years ago
is when i started messing with it i
started doing um a little bit of video
game art and to be honest it was like a
lot of it started i started actually
thinking and becoming more inspired than
i ever had been when i started playing
d1
because a lot of the
like the look of the of the the the way
that weapons and like architecture and
vocals and stuff
i was just like this is
like so inspiring and so i just wanted
to kind of tear them out and think of
each individual weapon as like literally
the first sketch i ever did was the like
a side view of the multi-tool the mighty
multi-tool and i had that original
like layout of that painting that i did
in my head for like four years before i
even did it and then whenever maybe not
fourth like two or three something like
that so however long it is from 2014 to
2017 or 18 i think
again so bad at that but like you know
it it finally pulled that out and then
it was like unplugging
like
you know letting the damn just like
burst open yeah i had been i've been
doing like one or two paintings a year
one or two like big projects a year
while working in i.t
in in like downtown dc and stuff like
that and i just was i was getting tired
of it and
i took a jump and started doing it
pretty much full time and i've been
kind of on and off full time since then
i mean the pandemic has been kind of
wild in terms of the way it affected
everything i was a redacted farmer for a
while that i told you all about
just a big plant it's tall it's like a
tree
i mean you you ain't redacted much right
now
a lot of a lot of farms are plants that
probably
said it's corn
but it's uh yeah no it's like as he
passed through the midwest he farmed
corn
yes yes
exactly
yeah no but but yeah it's um i do aside
from the the credits that y'all listed
off i do like a couple other things i
work for like a small
i do contract work for like a small
educational company that makes um
like i think it's k through five k
through six something like that reading
and uh comprehension skill stuff it's
pretty cool like
um
the the lady who hired me was like a lot
of people find it boring and i was like
a lot of people need a paycheck
um
and it's it's nice too because it's like
it's actually kind of
it's
it's
i'm struggling to think of the word but
it like it builds things you know what i
mean it's like constructive it's not a
destructive i don't i'm not doing
graphic design for a company that's out
there like tearing down the rainforest
or making actual weapons or something
like that right like i'm i'm working for
somebody that makes learning materials
and then the stuff i do where i i work
for get contracted for
you know different things with other
companies i try to stick with places
that are
like
have a positive impact on the world and
that's that's why
when guardians asked me to help them i
was definitely into that and
rick at blueberries is they make he
makes content for people who want to
learn how to play the game like who want
to come into destiny and get better at
it and that's the same thing with
massive breakdowns too is like i was
gravitated towards them for so long
because i was always thinking about how
to get better at the game how to get
better at pvp especially because i'm
terrible at it and there's like so much
room for growth there but like
it it's fun running segment here
yeah yeah it's it's yeah it's i mean and
it's fun to like connect with these
folks who know those things like i love
when people know
like about a build or something that
that gets you further because you
experimented or you went and you did the
research and the community had come
together and built this tool that you
could snap in like with your dim like
there's the dude uh mejiago who built
the like the armor picker i'm pointing
at my screen like you all can see it but
like
this over here that totally makes right
now
like
you know that was huge like finding
people who had built so many like
constructive and functional pieces of
the community and being like you know
you can like plug these two things in
together and this person designed this
to fit with this and i'm just like
i have a tier three armor build now like
there you go
yeah i was like i think destiny has had
quite a journey for all of us sounds
like yours has been
kind of two tracks at the same time both
the game and then the
art appreciation as well as kind of
you're doubly vested in the game we
typically just have the gaming side all
of us are actually well content creation
podcasting yeah we're all over yeah
that's true
multiple faster
literally
yeah for how long the game got previewed
by the time this saga finishes it's
going to be like a quarter of my life
that this game has been around
have you guys ever thought of if you
would be
if you would still play destiny if you
didn't
do something for it
oh yeah i and the other way around too
like
i'm gonna keep playing this game and i
want to stop
like mickey's acting yeah yeah yeah
yeah like i wonder all the time like
would i play destiny if i if i didn't
have to
i was i i was the last of my friends to
keep going
yeah so it was like i was the one doing
this all the time
all your events solo
yeah so like yeah most of my friends
fell off so i had to
get through a bunch of stuff on my like
i don't have anybody to play with but i
got to get a nightfall done let's figure
this stuff out like it was it was that
kind of thing so i mean some of that was
and it has always been this thing that
has had a good cadence of releases now
but as you said on the other side
basically i got about nine hours out of
breath of the wild and then destiny
pulled me away i didn't really get to
horizon until this year because of
destiny so it's been
also the opposite of
maybe there's stuff i wouldn't have
missed if i wouldn't have been covering
it but on the other side it's been a
hell of a so it's been a bit of both i
mean yeah it's it's hard to know for
sure
for your friends to pull away from you
on destiny
so it was probably after
war mind for me most of the people
ps4 kind of bailed
um
but i switched over to pc like
to like maine
maybe like it launched
halfway oh i mean i played it when it
launched on pc also because i was very
curious how it feel yeah that's a big
deal but like
i i picked it back up again maybe like
four or five months later
and i had had a buddy that had also done
the same thing and he was like finally
another person so we do owed a bunch of
stuff
from like that's funny you know i think
i think my friends left
two weeks after d1 launched it was like
very short window and then i was just i
was running solo for
you know
until today basically
um so yeah
it's interesting yeah for me it was
the people were there for the beginning
but you were into it
right right because you were a destiny
hater for a while no i was a destiny
hater i liked i liked the i was in the i
was the alpha for the beta because
playstation had the alpha xbox had the
beta i was in the beta i liked it played
on the campaign and i'm like i don't get
it
like i mean don't get me wrong i like
the feel of the game i thought it looked
cool but i played it like a traditional
game like it was a start and a finish so
when i finished and then the speaker did
that little speech and and that and then
you know i'm like
a stranger
and then i'm like
where is this where is this epic halo
story
like
just the end the quote unquote what i
thought was the end left the kind of
sour taste of my so i was like all right
i'm done and it wasn't for like i said
my shout out to my friend sinister it's
like no you know you know the whole
forever 28 and get to level 30 and then
we got to do this raid and i'm like for
what like i've done what i had to do
it's like no bro you have to yeah i was
like for what
was this vlog was this like yeah
yeah that's why vlog is always gonna
have a special place because i was done
with this game i was just like yeah
whatever and i'm like yo what is this
this is crazy like six people doing
something and figuring things out and
the game's not holding my hand or
telling me
and it was just moments actively pushing
you down and going why did you do this
i can't jump on this platform and i'm
like all right and then the oracles was
a fun thing it was like all right
listen to the beeps
i'm like all right okay i see that one
that one it was just little fun goofy
thing that i've never seen a game
cooperatively do
for console in the fps space
it's like it it it followed kind of the
path of the way that like wow did
certain things yes and i had played
final fantasy 11 so i was familiar with
doing like large player like large group
content oh okay
like feeling that in first person
it blew my mind i never did anything
cooperatively like that before and it
was puzzle solving it was platforming
the dps phase stuff bosses i'm like yo
what is this this is this is dead i'm
like i became the champion defender of
destiny and you are not going to slander
this game because i would always call i
would pull like a travis like i would
call him up did you do the rain but he's
doing great though oh no i didn't do the
rain ah shut up because you didn't
get back
and then i started converting people it
was like a church of cog it was like
yeah you did great now that's all
it did people and then the pastor left
for pc and then his congregation was mad
for a while you
you were uh you you yeah and i was the
devil on your shoulder who pulled you
out of the congress out of church yeah
yeah you
my buddy just did that too that's with
the fov even further are you serious
beautiful so good it's so good oh my god
vision extra peripheral vision and
everything you play my buddy just did uh
yeah it was the new i think it's the
alienware quantum dot
ultrawide that's like pretty recent so
it's like 240 hertz 1440 quantum dot
like
and he just he's been missing he's like
i always like gave ultrawides a hard
time he's like
damn it and he loves it now he's like i
got my 4k 144 hdr and that's like but
then yeah the the ultra live
the nice piece to have but i can't have
all the room right now
and all you have to do is well three
hours a week maintaining your pc
yeah i mean i don't though i really
don't that's the thing like as long as
you don't pour a bucket of liquid in the
top of your pc you'll be okay
that was a lie that happened live to me
on that yes i know believe me you should
not get it
yeah that was a heart attack and a half
we had tom warren on from the verge yeah
we had a
big guess yeah big gaston
right before the show like we're in
pre-chat like we were before yeah and i
had like a whole eye shaker of advanced
gg mixed by the way
and like the top like i knocked it and
it goes into the top and it's i gotta i
had recently got a case that the top is
open so it's got high airflow like
exhaust yeah so it just went in and it
dripped down the entire it's red
i pulled the plug i ripped everything i
think it was bathing it in alcohol at a
point in time yeah like it's still alive
so it it lives but man yeah
nearly me
and we were like what is going on
is one of those moments where like your
wife knows you well enough she just
heard me cursing
constantly
and she was like i just left you in the
room i knew you were okay but i'm not
going to get near it
i'm scared of death for you
liquid cooling that's liquid cooling
yeah
unfortunately the only way to really do
that's mineral oil but yeah it's a whole
different fun product that's the story
of why he started hating sauces
especially earth sauce
he
and get him dirty
seriously
all right well we got some stuff going
on in this game uh that was a nice
little transition fun piece there a
little throwback memory pain it's fine
now i'm hurting in the head and in the
knee so it's good
no so iron banner i did actually get the
title did it the night before because
they had like three and a half hour
maintenance so it's not going to be able
to get up and get it
uh i did polish that title off i think i
got it at like midnight went to bed and
i was like cool
nice i wanted to get you guys thoughts
on
iron banner on rift with they did get
the mercy changes if you get i know
travis you haven't been but for those of
you guys that play
how
how is iron banner how did riff end up
for you guys
how did it go because i know
cog you didn't play with mercy because
you were done
uh
but you had but you had a faster run
through the title than i did
for a special someone in the chat that's
here that wants to hear the story when
it's my turn i'll i'll
i mean
you can't just like leave us hanging
that's like jumping on the end of the
diving board and being like
i'm fine
shout out to my camera he's in the chat
right now very salty dj oros
second place
oh
that's too soon
this cab's a song let's do something
anyway shout out to dj
dj has left the chat is what you
shouldn't say
so you know
remember we had the conversation before
with when bannon was announced we were
all concerned like yo
you know the limited time there's only
two two weeks or whatever that you could
do it how would it work what if you
missed it he was in that situation where
he literally had to work predominantly
the first week it was out now in his
defense you know it was double xp that
week right you know i was in there
grinding grinding because i'm like you
know what i don't know how it was one of
those rare moments trav work was like i
don't got a lot
going on with covering games to let me
knock it out and i did the grind the
hardest part was just the prestigious
two times and the the objective portion
make sure you touch the spark kills
white was fall touch the spark just to
get that progression right so i get it
at the 11th hour knock it out so now
well i'm better come back around
i am so burnt out i'm like i am not
touching that i am not doing that i'm
taking a mental destiny break i see my
whole clan in there cut nope i'm over
here i'll be over here doing the rock
and blade point or playing these other
one player games this is what i'm doing
to mentally decompress from that torture
that i went through right
so i'm watching him and my poor boy man
dj he's like the last day he's grinding
and literally bungie says like what is
it a couple of hours before reset
so they have one hour longer maintenance
than they
maintenance
and it's one hour longer than we
normally do and we do it before the
reset and he put a screenshot of the all
he needs is the prestige the second one
and the circle is 90
with that little opening before and he's
trying to grind
and they shut it up he's like [ __ ] i
can't get in and i'm like are you
serious sounds like it's usually like an
hour you good he's like no it's like
there was gonna be three there was going
to be three hours of maintenance they
had mentioned that on like a tweet or
the 12 or something but it ended up
being like four hours of maintenance
like they did they made it even longer
that was the thing about it
look i felt this pain because my whole
my only thing look maybe this is gonna
happen but the thing that killed is like
to do a mate this before in the middle
of a special event when you don't get
this the same amount of time that the
first group had
it's kind of tough you know what i'm
saying i get it
you also couldn't get the same
multiplier you stopped at 8.8 x you
could only like you guys had 11x and you
guys had double rep because yeah they
had the errors
and yet they didn't double the rep at
all for this week even though you
couldn't get the full reputation game
and that i felt was unfair to you guys
and him in that respect i get it yeah
bro play to get i get it for the people
who you know who are not sympathetic but
i just felt like yo they should have the
equal conditional on some level and it
just sucks because i know you really
wanted the title really bad but that was
the story my clan is the ones who have
it are teasing the hell out of him like
hey bro i don't know if you could be an
honorable podcast without the iron lord
we got a check
we'll let you back in next season when
you get the title yeah he's getting
clowns he's right now on the hot seat
you know he's on probation until next
season uh that's
tough
that's what that was the story
so did you get did you play much at all
res
yeah i got it first week um
[Music]
i was i was a little obsessed with the
first week because i was telling y'all
before we started like iron banner is
the that's the reason i started playing
pvp in destiny in d1 in like the first
place is the thing that actually got me
inspired to try for once because i'd
always mess around with pvp a little bit
but like iron banner has always been one
of my favorites and
i was kind of bummed that they took
power level out of it just because it's
like there's very few places where it
matters at all and like
because i play so much pvp and like to
do like raid helps and stuff like that
like i end up pretty highlight pretty
quickly
just smacking people in that first week
that's what you're saying and always
felt pretty good to be over leveled in
the first time so you just enjoy
crapping on the little guy that's fine
but uh um
the change is
the changes like especially from the
first week that they did it to this this
past week when they did it were amazing
i really had a good time with rift so i
had a lot of fun playing objective mode
uh i played with people so like the part
where you had to
actually like touch the spark and like
run the spark we took turns
oh
god was like yo i still need this many
points and it's like why don't you just
try to carry this time we'll guard you
on the way there
and it works because you're already
trying to play that mode you're already
trying to guard someone who's going to
run for you anyway or you're trying to
like you know guard somebody who's got
they're going to be able to buff you
your garden the hunter there's run an
omniock something like that you want to
that sort of thing so it was
i
liked it a lot i liked that it was a
limited map rotation
i could do without its convergence right
the way it used to be
virgins just because a it feels pretty
broken one of the spawns is is pretty
broken it's pretty easy to spawn trap
people there
um and i'm also just i don't
i don't want to play on convergence
anymore i'm sorry a lot of people have
had some
couple different videos and podcasts
like a lot of people just you know that
map apparently can now go in the bushes
people are kind of done with that one
it's just it's just time you know and i
don't want to like it's not as kind of a
dead horse thing but like not having new
maps and
you know
playing a lot of the older ones a lot
just does feel pretty bad like i would
prefer new stuff that's a huge time
investment from their team
and
honestly i've been really hit or miss on
the new ones like i didn't like the new
vex one they threw in i actually i feel
like i'm on the other side of a lot of
people i really like um the new throne
world one two sub
[Music]
it's a cool cool very darkness sounding
words
yes
um i like that junction
disjunction this junction okay
it does have like i like that it has
like three very distinct parts and so
you get different engagements and
different parts of it like there's that
middle part that starts to feel a little
closed in but it's actually still open
you've got like the cubbies on either
side and you've got the like little top
places where people can try to hide um
then it's got like the big pond area and
then the area heavy spawns is like
they're all very different and it gives
it lends to like different play styles
it allows
players to have much more varied
loadouts because there are places where
especially on a mode like rift it's like
if they take the spark in that back
hallway
you're going to fight in the back
hallway like you don't get to be like
well i want to engage you out here
like oh you go you have to go to the
objective
like it actually it gets the engagements
to actually kind of flow a little bit
more and
the mercy changes were just perfect yeah
how was that i missed out on that
so you played the first week
it was
bad you were just yeah
i was just sick
and this time it was so blazing fast if
it was a blowout it was like a mercy on
any other kind of match or mode where it
just got you right through and
it was also it felt a lot more fair and
respectful of the time it cut out the
ability to really easily um
uh like grief people with the the
teleporting glitch at the end and so
all that felt pretty good and i mean i
know it's iterative they've they've done
so many changes so many different ways i
like this one
i'm i'm not so salty about the stuff
that i don't like that i'm not gonna you
know it's not gonna override for me so
i've had a good time messing around with
it and a lot of people especially like
we had some old ps4 uh clan members who
were having some fun like jumped in with
us and
you know cross safe and cross play were
like the greatest things that ever
happened in this game y'all were talking
about like pc we were talking about like
different platforms it was hard like it
was hard yeah so being able to actually
have like a big playlist and a big group
of people that can just hop in together
is
that i mean that's that's when destiny's
at its best
190 100
yeah i mean for me i had the mix because
i played about one reset the first week
um
and i did everything solo like the
entire thing so it's freelance the
entire time
yeah freelance the whole time no if you
god if you're solo and you don't know
freelance exists it's probably like
sometimes it's a little better because
people forget that there's two buttons
yeah well that's when you guys
what i don't understand is like
if you're in a team this is where like i
know crucible matchmaking is a thing but
somehow i hear people who run a sixes be
like oh we turn we we win against
another team of solos and there's like
six solos and you're like i know there's
people running groups out there finding
the other group
like that should be a high price you see
sixes like you're going six or a five or
a four long before it's like everybody's
by themselves versus a team this seems
okay it makes people love you dodge too
right it makes people like work to
actively lobby dodge and i'm not gonna
lie i've done it like i've been the
party leader that's sitting there
watching oh we're about to get match
against the six back out like
you know especially if it's especially
if you're just in there with like one
buddy right you're in
no i do not want to play with four
randos
and a six stack like
match me somewhere else please yeah
exactly
so yeah the matchmaking
i will definitely say the mercy was big
because if it got to
if you got stopped zero to three it's
over and it was like that could be a two
and a half minute round or the other
side if you got another spike right
thirty seconds
yeah on the pins on the map like i
one time like in that night when i was
like trying to finish up i was on a
group and i went one two and three and i
dunked all three so i have like the
saladins run metal or whatever it was
three and oh nobody killed me nobody
touched me like 100 and like i got it
never probably gonna happen again but
it's because bannerfall if you get those
early kills and you pick it up and you
as soon as it's done
you dunk before they can ever come back
like banner falls the one
where you can do it without trying
the other map that's not going to happen
the big one disjunction that's weight
yeah and because that it's a
there's no lane directly to it you have
to move
up so far to get to a lane on that map
like but better fall you just like get
to the hallway and everybody's there
like ready to fight in the hallway but
but i will say for the mode it is nice
to have an objective and like yeah i had
my own threes and three knows those
happened plenty as a solo player because
you're like oh there's two people on
this team and just mowing everybody down
it's like whether you're on the good
side or bad side of that equation you'll
see it it was the ones where like the
spark would be like oh it died oh it
died over here oh it died over here it's
moving like back and forth and you're
like waiting for it those were the fun
ones actually it's like yeah you went to
the time some people like oh i had to go
to time on the match but i'm like but
the back and forth like the tug of war
of moving that spark back and forth
that's when i'm like then this actually
feels like kind of a balanced room and
that's when i do like the idea of
everybody converging to a point and then
like those moments where a super golf
you're like oh damn it like perfectly
time super because you're usually pretty
grouped together and that one like blade
barrage just wipes after
it's those moments so
yeah it's like you see
sorry go ahead go ahead i was just gonna
see that back and forth that i really
enjoyed when those happen and it felt
like the lobby was
about right for it that's when i did
have fun when it was like stop stop stop
stop either side of that it was like
yeah it's nice to get the quick win
because i'm just trying to knock out
objectives for the title but the matches
where i was like actually getting into
it when it was like
one to one
and then you ran out of time and then
all three of them came up and you had
the triple spark and the hilarious thing
was in its triple spark i love going
down the middle and everybody goes
outside i'm just like straight down the
middle and taking the wind yeah yeah
everybody's like oh i'm gonna go where
they don't think i'm gonna go and i'm
like nobody chose the middle
touchdown let's go that was pretty rare
too but like did you see it do you feel
like you saw a pretty good mix of people
doing different like subclasses
different loadouts or
because i mean
definitely didn't feel one note for me
no i will say i i
i play a lot of solar just because solar
has been 3.0 and i love my solar titan
anyway so i was like i've been playing
that a lot but i mean i got frozen
plenty i will actually say between
mayhem and then also being a solar titan
i can't tell you how annoyed i am
sometimes how weak my hammers actually
feel i love using them
but against any other super we suck
it feels so funny to hear that because i
feel like they smash into my face so
often oh no you don't know how many
people in super i'll hit you once
like you know there's a shade binder
i'll hit him in the face with a hammer
and then they freeze me and then i can't
do anything and yet my body's on fire
and i'm frozen and then they pop me
or there's a nova bomb and it's like if
that's coming at me or golden gun can
instantly i'll even throw my hammer and
it's like it'll trade in mid-air but
it's like it's not there fast enough so
it's like
the
it it feels like i can hit people with a
hammer and not kill them but i tend to
get like i don't win many trades as as a
titan super it's weird
i have a buddy that means titan and he
he's been doing a lot of solar and i
know that there was also part of the
title and the quest well it's i guess
not quest but like part of it was to use
solar void because they're the new ones
oh for the daily challenges yeah yeah
yeah yeah but i i did fairly different
like a grouping of people and the minute
i was done with mine the first week i
switched back to stasis because i i like
running stasis with the renewal grasps
in crucible right now because it's like
building out little zones where your
team can be a little bit like area
denial but you also get some buffs from
it the way you run an exotic
and so like that was fun and
it's just still different like i feel
like they've balanced most of them
pretty good i am very interested in arc
3.0 oh
i was an archdance arc dancer that's not
right
blade dancer
blade but blade dancer was the old one
what's the arc drive writer schneider
see they've seen what they are dancing
i've forgotten
i know but like arcstrider was bothered
at the electric nightclub yeah
it was good dude i like it's it's one of
those ones especially in sixes and
especially in banner when you had like
when they were still doing control if
you popped off i have a buddy that that
mostly mains uh stormcaller and it's
like if you pop off on arc even still
you can get a go a little hard on people
and they don't necessarily expect it and
i know that
the big pvp guys have like
you know talked about like the best arc
builds and stuff like that but i can't
wait until we get the new version and
get to like absolutely pick all the
pieces so that one down absolutely and i
want to see what they lean into
obviously you know void had with
suppression and some healing
verbs or whatever right yeah i want to
know what the verbs are going to be
because like i got a lot like ignition
i'll be honest i i i i was wrong about
sun oh incandescent makes ignition yeah
like
okay
no that's all i was going to say is like
my callous minitool doesn't come off
oh yeah i don't level 52 right now it
doesn't come off i just blow stuff up
right now if i'm farming finally got
that like i said the thing and
the the bills and i'm building it out oh
shout out to i didn't realize how much
they really improved the crafting
mechanics
we're changing um actual perks on the
fly without the material investment very
low i'll just understand that
oh yeah it's just game changer yeah and
you can you can swap stuff you still
have to pay to put a new one in but you
don't have to like if you don't change
stuff it stays and you just pay the the
remainder basically that because i i did
that with my last week
like
finished it and i was like oh i forgot
to actually put like the masterwork
frame piece on it and i went back and i
was like are they going to charge me
another i would say
okay cool cool cool cool
thing i'm like yo how much does going to
cost just to change this thing out and i
was testing it with a peace of mind and
then i had to i was able to double um
enhance perk with um what is it the um
elemental capacitor and perpetual motion
and that's like my god roll that's my
baby and i had dub i had um
just the elemental capacitive portion
enhanced so i was like you know what i
got enough materials i figured it's
going to cost a whole bunch i got i got
everything now so i'll invest so when i
went to do it they were like oh no all
you got to do is change just one thing
it's only going to cost this a little
bit of neutral elements and your master
workers i was like oh okay
finally reasonable
yeah you're so right like it was way too
complicated to begin with way too and it
could have been worse as travis is very
happy it's not but uh i gotta shift the
conversation just so this podcast
doesn't take too long
um
no solstice launched on tuesday now i
know travis has been
busy
have you i want to get travis's head
like
rumblings through the streets before we
get into those that have played because
if he hasn't dove in yet i want to see
what it sounds like from the outside to
travis so how has solstice sounded like
to you
yeah so obviously last week i was on the
show talking about how upset i am about
all the new currencies in silver ash and
yada yada
um
i did not get a chance to play so i
haven't had time to investigate myself
but interestingly
a close friend of mine who i've had for
a while and and gamed with in the past
recently was peer pressured by his
friends into playing destiny 2. and boy
is he going through the ringer all of
the
worst new light
her fuffles you could imagine and just
it's very very funny watching him go
through it because he's like hey travis
you heard of this game called destiny
and i'm like
yeah a little uh
a little bit yeah just a
small amount here's a show you can watch
me talking about it for 500 hours
um yeah so
it's been interesting because uh
he is um he's on my table top rpg group
so he's a uh
a a numbers nerd and he really likes
like uh
build crafting and in every game he
plays he's just like kind of a
meticulous dude so the first thing he
did was you know go to reddit and watch
youtube videos and figure out all the
different ways to get like your stats
high and what's important and what's
important and just like ultra ultra meta
gaming which i hate when he does it when
we're you know tabletop rpgs but in a
video game you know that's the name of
the game it's like we're supposed to do
so
um yeah uh it's been very fun watching
his reaction to solstice
he is so confused
and uh it's just added a layer on top of
that and it's very funny when he's like
wait so you're on a show where you talk
about this and you can't tell me what
these silver leaves are for and i'm like
that is correct sir welcome to the world
of destiny where even the experts are
idiots for
a little bit
at least
part of every week when it resets for an
event where part of every week we're all
morons yeah exactly
so
yeah it's been uh it's been very funny
so he told me a little bit about what it
was i was like actually yeah i'm
supposed to talk about that tomorrow
night why don't you why don't you tell
me what your first impressions are so
his first impressions are he's liking
the drops and hating everything else and
i was like okay that sounds like destiny
so um yeah that's that's that's all i
got i have not jumped in yet but
after uh after i write my first drafts
tonight i'm hoping to get on and play
saturday sunday have you spent some time
around the bonfire yet
i'm not i have not um like i said i was
on my sabbatical
and uh i'm back i'm coming outside now
and i i i looked at you you take public
sabbaticals as opposed to some people
quit destiny oh yeah like exactly
you know you're lying you coming back
because you know what's funny
this
i gotta tell this this is funny i was
mad last week i was like man i'm not
doing that i've been man i saw the
solstice rewards i ain't doing that
yeah and then i will talk about next i
saw a certain trailer
i witnessed a certain trailer and i was
like
i said that i laughed at myself trap and
i'm like
this marketing team does this to me
every cycle i could i was literally i
would say it's completely fine you can't
quit man yeah i wasn't furious with the
gardener knows about that no just
kidding
yeah like i have a little line
like no destiny i'm not playing you i'm
going to be productive i'm going to get
other games finished
i am good and then that trailer came and
i was like and then i said all right
well let's see what's going on with
soldiers let me watch any boxes video
and see what's going on and then you
know the only thing i will say and i'll
give it to you guys that have actually
played is that i don't know how i feel
about from a warlock perspective the
armor just yet i don't know how i feel
about it just yet so i'm curious about
the the titan and the
hunter delegation how you guys feel
about your set i don't know how i'm
there just yet i cannot get on board
with the titan helm i'll tell you that i
got stuff that goes this way and this
way
like what direction is the little frill
gonna go all of them off of the helmet
like the rest of the body i'm actually
cool with the helmet looks like there's
one too many bows on it pick a direction
and stick with it i don't need to have
the full compass rose on the top of my
head and little frill bows the body
actually doesn't look bad though even
though the sun's on the shoulders are
kind of big but res how has it been
treating you before i go into my detail
since i've done this thing
just to
go off what you were saying like i
and i this is always kind of weirdly
disappointing when this happens but i
saw the concept art for the for the
solstice armor and i like the art like i
like the sketches of it so much more
than i like how it looks in the product
and it is so weird and it is also like
the sketches this is they had done these
really expressive the titan looked like
real beefy and like it was like a little
different so i think they were kind of
making it look a little different than
it would in the game no matter what
but i just think the sketches were
gorgeous and i i do like
the armor with some of the shaders but i
gotta say like that solstice is kind of
like my least favorite style
in terms of the stuff they've added and
i understand like i get it it's the the
sort of lore through line that goes like
this was the armor you were supposed the
parade armor you were supposed to have
on the beginning of d2
when we were like celebrating how we had
like those come coming to a new golden
age is going to be great and then the
cabal attack and so like you have that
whole
the whole story and then they the very
first season when they made it like the
parade armor exactly and it was just
glowing and it's like oh okay cool
that's i get what you're doing
every time since then it's always been a
little like
i don't necessarily like the the look of
it but
it's fine it's cool it also kind of
always gets me a little grumbly
uh when i have to build a whole new
armor set when i've spent so much time
with the builds that i have because i
have like
four or five really specific builds that
i use for specific things and
the best thing they ever did when it
comes to that is when they said like
we're not going to sunset armor at all
like you're just cool like we have these
new armor pieces this is the way this is
going to work from now on and i was like
because i would have had to like every
season yeah yeah
okay this piece is now like trash and
i've got to make sure i'm spending my
currency in to keep it so like
artificially adding that on top has
always been kind of a bummer but the
event i was just before we jumped in i
was i was doing a strike just to get a
feel for because all i had really done
was the actual event so far but i wanted
to play something in the playlist where
it gives you the reward cycle where it
sort of says okay now go back and do it
right right i've never minded that
because like there's always like you're
coming in you're going to do your
pinnacles you're going to do your weekly
stuff
you do that you grab everything and then
now there's an extra layer
multitasking they add them the extra
piece and i've never really thought of
those events as like well that piece is
the core of the game like that piece is
always the extra piece so getting a
chance to like i'm gonna play some
matches like i'm gonna do some strikes
i'm gonna run my my gambit for the week
like i'll get all these things then i'll
be able to shuffle them back into this
other thing and
what i i find they tend to do and i
don't know if people ever really focus
on this so much i've never really heard
people talk about this as a cyclical
thing but like towards the end of the
season they tend to always give us a
bunch of stuff that's going to front
load us
for the next season you're going to be
able to get a ton of extra legendary
shards whether it's a glitch or not but
like you're going to be able to get a
ton of extra legendary shards or master
records or whatever and then
because it's also like you don't have to
start doing your full end game chase at
the very beginning of every season
because you can't get to gm's yet the
raid probably isn't out yet even when it
does you got a weak a contest mode etc
like there's always reasons that the
game is sort of choked off one way and
asking you to do these other things in
other ways and i think if you
like the people who seem to have the
best time with it tend to follow that
flow through where it's like okay
beginning of the season i'm going to try
these things i'm going to learn what
they've added they've got a new story
piece that they're going to have me
check out and
what's the thing that they added on top
of that oh it's this kind of
battleground or this kind of arena
shooter thing where it's like you guys
are not arena shooter but you know what
i mean like the arena like mobbed like
mob modes or or horde
that we've gotten like that throws in on
top of it and you go like okay this
stuff extra very good and i like this
season's version where it's um it's a
little bit more like
sort of uh like hunter killer sort of
thing you got to go find oh there's a
spawn over here this one's really quick
i got to take this i can run and it's
keeping you more mobile instead of
keeping you locked in these little
corners of the map for like
a fifth of the map fifth of the match is
over here and then it's over here and
then it's over here it's like very
dynamic and i always forget you can pull
your sparrow out on that map because
yeah yeah
yeah you can just like get
scoot across the map
i'm always like trying to run like oh i
bet i can get up here and then i can do
a super like jump just fall over there
and it's like you could have ridden your
space jet ski
i could have straight
yeah
the loot thing the the currency thing
like
i understand what they're trying to do
like from a design perspective that it's
like they want us to have an interesting
and engaging look through it but it is
so confusing oh you don't say
so confusing every time
you don't like digital currencies and
it's what is it like i didn't i
experimented with it a little bit but
you have to like one of the currencies
you use to unlock another thing on your
armor all right let me break it down
it's just like
you did you want me to discard these
after or no because because some of it
looks like you could probably like
really spice them up and like get some
interesting things like if it stays
permanent but are they going to take
away the extra stuff at the end of the
event like i don't know probably yeah so
yeah short yeah so
bring it down
yeah that's it let's get it let's hear
it i've already done this for a whole
video so it's fine um
you have silver leaves you get those by
doing other things in the game then the
actual bonfire bash event
now
even as of right now because as a 48
minutes ago they're like silver leaves
have been fixed or dropped from these
activities actually nine minutes later
they're like uh not all of these things
are fixed
yeah so
okay up until about 48 minutes ago on
twitter sever was not dropping altars of
sorrow was not dropping patrols which
are literally one of the challenges not
dropping blind well part of the
challenge dares of eternity part of the
challenge all of these were not dropped
they're they're one of the event
challenges that you have to like go in
and do you can't get leaves and the
leaves don't drop from some of the
things that the thing asks you to go do
i think it sounds like it sounds like
that might be so kind of late
oh yeah really it looks like they
deleted one of those and that somehow
and then the correction is now silver
leaves are
maybe dropping from patrols and silver
but the other things are still not fixed
so
then you've got
it's all all coming together i get why
it's called silver leaves because after
listen
silver is going to leave
because
nobody's going to want to play the game
anymore it's good so i will actually say
chris buff last week had mentioned
chris buff had actually mentioned last
week about the para causal tree and
that's actually what these are from so
it is an explanation from eva levante
that these are from
like found i think from amanda holiday
they were from like this tree of silver
leaves or whatever whatever it was
they're pericausal leaves is what they
are they are actually
she says that in her bungie or her
banshee lore yeah okay it's somewhere in
there yeah
so the idea is you go do other
activities to get leaves
the leaves you take into bonfire bash
bonfire bash is the eaz if you picture a
forge
because you kill
guys that glow when they drop they drop
an orb you throw the orb into the middle
bonfire
okay got it like they are yeah like
literally just like the forges in
well seasonal force oh yeah yeah yeah or
season of the worthy you're throwing an
orb into a central location got it okay
uh okay
you can be halfway across the map and it
just kind of like weaves its way there
as long as you give it a decent arc
you're good
is it kind of magnetic
yeah kind of you run into stuff it'll
run in yeah you got to be you got to
have a good line and give it a decent
arc but i mean it's
halfway across the map with a decent arc
like it's good it'll get there so it's
it's nice you don't have to go get close
so
then when you finish depending if you
can get up to 20. we talked about this
last week travis they did cap it
so at 20
orbs thrown in and and bonfire like
igniters in there
uh um
basically a big taken ogre will show up
he's a boss you nuke him dives really
fast then you go up to the bonfire and
for every leaf that you had up to 20
and then every orb that you threw in up
to 20 it will take one leaf and turn it
into five ash
so basically if you go in with 20 leaves
and you actually get all 20 orbs thrown
in then you're gonna end up with a
hundred silver ash
when
okay now the ash is
one the ash is one piece of the canden
of the seasonal armor
now the other piece of the armor is
kindling now kindling is what you you
get from the event challenge
i'm sorry
travis has been shot by a tranquilizer
he will come back to us shortly
all right so we got the ash and then we
do we get so the silver ash is one thing
then the other side you have kindling
you have like 24 event challenges like
remember the event card we talked about
those a little while ago they were
coming in for solstice you go and it'll
tell you
go you know throw 50 of the orbs into
the bonfire go get a certain number of
kills go run there's 24 of these things
every one that you do you get one
kindling
basically what you do is it takes six
kindling
to completely kindle
a slot
so if you put yeah so in say the helmet
you put one in
sorry continue it's like yeah
face up window yeah
uh so then so for take like the helmet
you would do small kindling as one
then large kindling is two and then to
fully kindle a slot is three so it's a
total of six kindling
two six times four no you do six total
kindling for one slot when you do if you
put all of those in your helmet you
never have to put kindling there again
the idea is you're upgrading the stat
potential of the armor
oh okay okay so it starts at like 49 and
then it's like mid 50s and then you can
mess with the 60s god okay so
let's do it so so so but but what about
the the actual mod slots available at
the lowest end of the kindlings we still
have a full you still have the mod slots
you just have crappy stats can i ask a
question
go for it yeah um is there any chance of
grasp of avarice level there's no
average there's no extra slot
yes no
it is like it the other side is like
instead of mod slots it's you could
really maximize like your like stat
potential yes so you
one potential pool stats and your bottom
is another potential pool like you can
min max within those pools a lot easier
because instead of waiting for the rolls
you can go like well i am going to
actually invest
into making mobility be the stat that i
want on that so it's config it is sent
it's like you said it's configurable
stat distribution yeah influencing that
on some level basically what happens is
like you've got a total of i think it's
like 34 35 36 on the top and you got
about and you have the same split on the
bottom and what happens is when you get
to the top tier of armor when you go to
actually like roll for your stats on
that piece of armor which i'll get to in
a second because you can only do it once
per piece i thought we could re-roll but
that was kind of misled
um
yes you buy another
but the idea is like
you're if you focus into say as a titan
i focused into resilience you're
guaranteed 20 there and then if you use
your ghost for
say recovery i'm guaranteed 10 there
that basically occupies the top because
there's like 30 something and you're
gonna have like two mobility so that
goes 20 resilience 10 in recovery
and then the other 30 stats is basically
distributed between the bottom so then
you can see like i got one where it was
like 20 10
15 and strength 15 and discipline like
damn near perfect roll and it was like a
67. and it's exactly where i want it
so if you focus it that way and for you
especially if you want a little more
recovery as a warlock say but maybe you
want mobility for a jump you don't care
about resilience then you'd go like high
recovery medium mobility and then just
you know do that on a couple pieces one
of your roles is probably going to put
the other the bottom half where you want
it
so
again as res said
if you've been playing for a while
and you have good armor stats you're
already set up with like i got three i
got a pvp set i got a pve set i got
another discipline set i'm good you're
not probably gonna get a whole lot out
of this
but as a free player especially or a new
player who has some time you have the
ability to actually like
build a set of armor that works
for
like into a very specific building you
could probably do a couple sets from
this if you have the time to do it
pretty quickly i mean aside from the
title like it's time but it is like you
could build like 66 67 is typically what
i end up with once you get a decent roll
and you can kind of
finagle the stats where you want to
probably more than we've ever been able
to right and it's already okay i'm sorry
good good
harder to understand that like unless
you're a
player who understands that well enough
like it may be harder to approach that
but like the potential is there and
they've done that with a lot of the
solstice events getting bigger
they've done things where we can get
really good armor from it pretty easily
like so but anyway you're gonna have to
when you do the final thing is it master
worked
you can still put it you can put the 10
energy in for like on top
i think you can just no yeah you can
master work yeah like like the plus two
on each
yeah yeah yeah you get the plus two on
each it's a normal piece of armor like
that it just doesn't have the artifice
slot it works like a normal piece of
armor yes but it's outside of this this
armor system and stuff
um
is there i'm hearing rumors of like i
don't know if it's a weapon or something
people are going crazy what are they
talking about like okay there is a
tortoise over there
oh yeah so it's the free
the one is like a 120 hand cannon it's a
stasis weapon can't get headstone
the other is the compass rose it's the
shotgun
this is from the last one they did it's
like i feel like yeah we've seen it
before or maybe i saw it in dawning i
feel like i've seen it before well i
mean the gun is
is better devils
like oh yeah the hand cannon yeah the
hand cannon's better
okay
it's origin
if you hit a target
and but you get an assist on that target
it will overload your weapon
what happens is people shoot it with
their weapon but then they'll switch
over to like gal horn
and then have their friend kill it now
their gal horn has like four shots
they'll switch back to their primary
they'll shoot it again the next person
the next enemy switch back to galley
have their friend shoot it now they have
six
like a six magazine of galahorn and they
can just go one two three four five six
without having to reload
is this how it was intended or is bungee
investigating is it correct it's
probably 100 busted
yeah i mean there's people there's no
way it's not gonna get fixed there's no
way because you have
people got like fourth horsemen 20 shots
in a row yeah that's fine yeah i've been
wondering
it was a very good video like watching
yeah
somebody had sweet sweet business with
over a thousand yeah that's neither meme
if you followed me
up more yeah had
1100 bullets in sweet business
there was one too that was like uh
someone posted a last word with like a
bunch of like last paragraph last
paragraph lesson closing argument it's
like it's like got a hundred bullets in
it merciless with like 21
on a boss
how is that not going to break the game
the same way that pocket infinity breaks
again that's basically yeah
[Music]
okay um but uh but the idea is
some of the challenges are not too bad
like throw 50 of the orbs in if you're
on top of killing the guys i'll usually
get like 10 around it's not too bad yeah
it's like because yeah some people like
oh where do i go i'm like i usually take
two of the spots and the other idiots
are running around and i take half of
them but
um
yeah so nice of me some are easy some
are just like kill certain enemies some
are get kills but then there's like 25
crucible or gambit matches that is one
of the challenges
one now they're not all that long uh
there's one in the throne world where
you have to do throne world activities
my advice is go do well spring
go do well spring because it's nine
leaves and ten percent so do that 10
times and you'll be good and dude you
probably still don't have those
craftable weapons
i don't i don't know you're right you're
right yeah you got that stuff
what'd you say
sorry all you have to do to complete it
is do an activity 10 times
oh
oh no you're not pumped
you die all i can say is when it comes
to the pvp matches
do it this week because mayhem is fast
if you if you don't do it this week it's
gonna be slower it's all i'm saying so
if you're
you don't have to do it at all but i'm
just saying if you do want to do this
mayhem is the fastest way to do the pvp
matches it sounds like he's a dad trying
to get somebody to do his whole work
like travis does not want to do his
homework travis is probably not going to
do this homework you're going to get an
amp on this assignment and just say i
got an incomplete
right that's right
so that is the general idea you go to
other activities you get leaves you take
the leaves to the bonfire bash when you
finish that they turn into ash the
challenges that you do you get each
challenge is one kindling and then for
the armor the kindling like fully
kindles the slots and then the ash is
where you re-roll for stats that's the
whole cycle of things
i said travis you gotta eat your veggies
the thing they don't tell you when
you're a child is that you actually
don't have to eat your veggies
you don't
and i pointed this out several times
break it down
um
and uh and i i feel like it's informed
my personality now as an adult question
let's make a question
well you don't
feel like am i gonna die without veggies
yeah exactly so uh yeah i i'm uh
i'm appalled
by this
i find it offensive and grotesque i mean
to to have it done to us yet again
is
and um
i'm disgruntled
i'm a disgruntled destiny player
are you gonna are you gonna form a union
and start striking
i think i might i think i might um
well yeah at the very least you should
make sure you write a very strongly
worded letter
that absolutely puts you in the
foreground because you're the perfect
kind of player that we absolutely need
to make sure the game is made for so
make sure you get that just like if it
doesn't fit in twitter just make sure
it's in a jpeg
and just be careful because also if you
it turns out you're doing some other
[ __ ] on the back end of that
you might get to yeah you might get just
don't get sued back that's what i'm
trying to do maybe just like outside
don't give up
very important yeah
for uh damages done to my psyche
clip from um
show as proof of my psychological damage
he died
it's fine these seasonal events i don't
know if they're for me some of them i i
will i will play it before the weekend
is elapsed but i i think it's like three
weeks or something right easy like three
weeks
more man it's just such a chore
i like i like the prospect of some
interesting weapons i love that there's
a bug in the game that's making people
do weird things
um yeah aside from that i think probably
the best parts of this event are
accidental
uh i was like i am two strikes and 12
crucial matches from having my flame
keeper title so i've done basically all
of it
is the
shirt is this one shirt is this shirt
the summer shirt yeah yeah this is the
orange solstice sun thing i wasn't
feeling the shirt even i haven't looked
at the shirt you said it's orange i'm
probably not going to get it yeah it's
okay like orange is it's a certain
person that can wear orange yeah red and
orange t-shirts i can't
neckties
[Laughter]
i respect that i just said they need
they'd
and i've had to make them all myself
yeah this is actually like this could be
this could very much be the like the
jerry garcia tie sort of thing where
it's like it doesn't have to have like a
picture like of cade on the tie it could
be something that's inspired by the
universe like the color and the texture
of a red legion tank perhaps
i will take literally anything at this
point you know
doesn't have to be creative just but no
they they release the only tie they
release is a warlock tie
oh he was meant to be brother come home
brother
i don't know
that has uh each of the classes no no
i'm saying very war like it's just
warlock specific
listen
so
it's here it's one of these like weird
things people do like
it's a long coat
it's a tie
it's a robe it's a robe
for unspecific reasons i have a vendetta
against armbands but uh i will um
i will buy the neckties for sure
i still need to see you in a bow tie i'm
surprised we haven't got a bow tie going
on yet
bow ties okay wait no you have you saw a
ghost that has a bow tie
yes yeah they're probably insane
witch queen release date i wore a tuxedo
and i had a bow tie oh okay
there you go
yeah i was like i don't remember
specifically that one but
i was like
i was like when it comes to they'll
bring this back a little bit when it
comes to the solstice event
it's
it is nice for certain players to be
able to build a set of armor if they
have the time to do it
but it is still i saw it you know i
think pigeon actually had a pretty good
thread on it it's like
you know the armor is kind of cool like
the glows we know like you're gonna have
the white ones you're gonna the white
ones are not as hard to get
they're really not uh you basically just
get the two sets of kindling and bam
your armor's glowing the color ones are
still purchasable through eververse so
you want to skip the whole process and
get some colors jump in there
um
it's just
it focuses us to go do the things that
we know need the most work we know
crucible is still lacking in maps right
now we know crucible
has its ups and downs in the sandbox
right now and it highlights it because
you have to go put 25 matches
in crucible
like strike playlists like we've played
a lot of these strikes many many times
and the fastest way to do the strike
because you can do like playlist
activities that's one of the challenges
but you have to do 25 crucible matches
and a certain amount of strikes and
nightfalls the playlist is going to get
done anyway
but when you go do the nightfall like
the nightfaller strikes
well the higher the level nightfall the
faster it goes so then i just played
prison of elders what i can't remember
the strike i played that 10 times so i
sat there and played the same strike 10
times in a row as opposed to the strike
playing list having variety i want to go
play mayhem
so it's just like it highlights the fact
that these things that we we don't we do
know need some work as they are the core
pillars of
everything they want us to do every
season is here's your story here's your
activity and here's these things it's
like we have tom on it's like the
seasonal stuff is usually pretty cool we
enjoy that but it's like the core
pillars of what we have to also get
pushed to go do
are the ones that just continue to show
you know games five years old and you
know how many times do you have to run x
strike and you're like yep just kind of
like literally could watch a netflix
show while doing some of this stuff so
just kind of bring some of that stuff
out and it's the whole go do other
things to bring this currency back in
here to do this thing yeah
and it's that whole cycle
i don't know it's like the event card
or the upgraded event card we talked
about it last time because we weren't
entirely sure because you can spend a
thousand silver and get this like
cosmetic package yeah
this is the shirt
yeah exactly yep it looks like it was
made by sun sunkist
you know as a somebody who likes sun
kissed that's actually not bad
got my orange crush baby yeah orange
crush there you go
those are the two orange sodas
not fanta no fanta no
i didn't realize that uh this was going
to bring up some strong emotions about
fanta yeah yeah
don't don't you want to talk about it
[Music]
but what i did kind of want to bring up
is because
this event you have leaves not dropping
where they're supposed to be dropping if
you try and do a second character
there's not a boost on the second
character so it goes faster second and
third characters were potentially bugged
iron banner we've had two weeks where
things went wrong
we have had a substantially buggy season
i would say
it feels like yeah for sure this one has
which i kind of want to take into
[Music]
i mean we can dwell on solstice if you
want to knock it out cool hopefully you
guys understand the purpose of it at
this point i feel like the activity is
eas is actually easier and quicker
you're not hunting for chests anymore
they made getting vertical easier
there's cannons that shoot you all over
the place like eac is almost like
cannons like eaz is
almost pretty passive you can have three
people sit where the little guys spawn
when the taken show up go kill them go
back to your three spots chunk the orbs
like
it's very low effort
and it does look like there's a little
bit of easter eggy stuff like there's
probably a secret thing or two that
we're gonna figure out somebody's
probably already figured out but i
noticed a couple things in like the way
certain things spawn that's similar to
previous seasons there's probably extra
stuff
if you're paying attention so
interesting yeah yeah
but i was like for me it's like
i know who it's for i like the idea of
flame keeper as a title just the wording
is cool i like flame keepers just sounds
cool so that's like one of the reasons
i'm kind of gonna knock it out
um
as for teddy there's the other title
reveler
which is gonna be you have to do all
four events over the course of a year
and it starts now so you gotta do
solstice
uh festival lust donning and guardian
games and after guardian games you can
actually get the title so
that one will be in the works for a good
bit
oh teddy so yeah that one's going to be
not completely ironic that they called
that one reveller because i don't think
the people who earn it are going to be
reveling much at all
quite upset
maybe
it's when they win guardian games they
revel in their victory and then they
log off the game and you know go crazy
isn't there
called the
okay well the other thing that happened
today is the giant piece of trailer 45
seconds to drop
those 45 seconds of the witness talking
to us
most of things i think we've heard
before but it basically says you don't
really have any more pieces to place
i've been sitting here a lot like i've
watched all of this happen
it's this exact monologue from the uh
yeah so it's the end of his monologue
but it's just like it shows
the history of the different things that
we've seen it shows the garden of
salvation where we talk to ourselves and
like the manifestation of the darkness
is like a clone it shows where the
pyramid ship got flashed over by the
light and where it kind of we the first
speckle of a pyramid ship even existing
uh we got to see you know the leviathan
hanging out by the moon and trying to
communicate with the pyramids we saw
kallus who now is going to be the
harbinger of the second collapse all of
these pieces now
and then of course the ending cut scene
with the witness from the witch queen
campaign
um
that kind of leads into it says the
destiny 2 showcase is going to be on
august 23rd august 23rd is the date of
the new season
so
a couple things we imagine this is going
to be
don't expect anything about the new
season until the day of because it's
probably going to be just like this
season was a couple hours before digest
it unless it leaks which then it'll go
live at like 10 o'clock at night so
perfect
um
so they'll do that but they're also
going to likely
be talking about lightfall
which i would imagine and this is
probably
we don't know when it's coming out
so that was kind of the first thing i
wanted to ask you guys we've talked
about it but res we haven't actually
talked about you guys
as we're going to see some type of teas
this early for lightfall
when do you expect lightfall to release
give me a month
what did we got which queen came out in
march february february
so like
my worry would be that they're kind of
stuck to the
pushed out deadlines that they had had
to make when they had to keep like
pushing the game the release back and
that it's just going to be
it was going to be like the year is just
now reset to
it's not coming out like when they used
to come out in uh october november it's
now gonna come out in early spring
um
i don't know where that that kind of
feels like where it's gonna go like
but you know that's what they said was
gonna happen they said that they they
wanted to make their annual releases
happen at the time as witch queen which
um
i could see
yeah i had previously theorized that it
was going to be an 18-month cycle from
now on just because they're working
remote and
uh
delays are inevitable especially when
you're pushing as much content as they
are
however an august 23rd
reveal
has me convinced it will come out in
spring next year so we'll see delays
always happen but my guess is
uh
at the event in august they will claim
that it's coming out in february or
march that's my guess and it might be
you know like that might be the plan
until they get bogged down
you know during that development cycle
because that's very very possible
yeah i just i don't i mean it's it's
impossible to tell how far along they
could possibly be on these things but
they had trouble with your year annual
releases for many years and i feel like
since they were independent and now uh
part of sony but apparently don't have
to answer to them anyway which is insane
to me uh and uh i think that they'll
they will probably defer to a more um
reasonable model and cadence that is
probably not annual that that would be
my guess it'll probably be like 15 18
months
[ __ ] where are you at yeah i was excited
and surprised i didn't expect this
um
shout out to the playstation logo at the
end
[Laughter]
i expected them to announce matter at
this point in the year i know i didn't
hire those pr people yeah i'm with you
i'm shocked that we got
potentially lightfall information you
know on a small level ahead of this new
game that everyone knows about but they
acted like we don't know about but
you know look i'm ex i'm excited for it
because it's the witness you know
ultimately it's the the true progression
of the storyline i like the callbacks i
like the guard to salvation reference
he's talking his talk he got the pieces
off the board i don't know why he
talking stronger we kill rope though i'm
like bro we killed your man like why why
are you bragging like that's some piece
we supposed to fear from your side but
whatever you know salute to him on him
you know he's doing his thing he talking
his little darkness talk but it was good
easy i still love the character i know
people have issues some have issues with
the way he look but i i think it's a
unique character design the way they
look
they yes yeah well i mean not even just
like we don't know what a gender is i
think it's a lot of beings
inside there
just like the the the smokey head and
this it feels like
it's giving me shang sung soul vibes and
i like that he's got all the souls of
the planets and the pyramids of this
evil assimilating race that do we know
and i did like the callus slow you know
reference like alice is down with the
home team over there salute to him he's
doing his thing
getting his little pyramid up ready to
attack us whatever you're doing you're
going jerry rig that that joint in the
moon i think look my prediction say it
now
callus is going to be a big part i think
i think he he jump a cable in that that
pyramid on the moon
i think that's going to be an integral
part to the attack on the traveler and i
do think we are going to be in serious
jeopardy with the traveler thus the name
lightfall right you know i think that's
the serious attempt on the line and i'm
very curious you know how that
transitions into what final shape
ultimately becomes
but i'm excited now the question becomes
like you said like
the cadence because now i'm totally with
trav
the the the the cycle of the activision
oh it's coming september
that's over
that's over they they clearly have
proven they cannot deliver the content
on that cadence anymore which probably
led to the split with activision in the
first place you know what i'm saying
because if you look at destiny 2's
history it was really supposed to be the
place of where rise of iron fell but
bungie pushed back thus they had a
smaller content drop with rise of iron
and then destiny 2 came out later so now
you're getting into this e where i feel
it's like
12 13 monthly kind of a deal
and
theoretically yeah that would fall
you know first half kind of a spring
2023 cadence the question is with covet
with what's going on are they
realistically gonna hit it but i have to
be honest trav the fact that they got
doesn't mean it can't get delayed but
the fact that we're getting this
technically two seasons ahead of time
is kind of interesting to me and that's
right out of their playbook that's
normal it is but i guess i didn't expect
it so i i thought you stayed gonna need
more time so now
i'm like well maybe
that you know
springy 2023 kind of release the only
issues
yeah
i think it's a lot more likely now as i
was expecting i was expecting matter to
get announced this summer and then
them to maybe announce uh light fall and
show more of it in like the fall of this
year and then it would probably get
delayed or or just straight up they
would just tell us like it's coming out
in september and they would switch to
like a 15 to 18 month cycle yeah
so um or like everything got pushed
because that right like the
announcements get pushed because the the
release got pushed and so it's like
you're saying cog is like it's you're
surprised the announcement came out now
it's because it did feel like it was
gonna get pushed back
the way that the other stuff got pushed
back like it feels like we were in
side that but you know it is nice to see
it like i i was kind of surprised
because i was like oh of course this is
when they tend to do that stuff and i
was like but wait we had because that
whole long season really like made
everything feel
like it didn't like i know they added
stuff in there when we got like dares
and we got the dungeon but it was
it made the cadence feel very different
yes it has since then so
it hasn't been sort of like easy to
understand yeah and once you read i
think like it's definitely
the vibe i get is kind of like an
internal shift and
you know yeah they seem ready they seem
ready anything could happen but that's
what i got i did not expect to see it so
now this is i'm going to assume trav
probably a gamescom kind of a
conjunction promotional piece then you
know interviews there maybe interviews
they're going to be outside yeah ready
to talk
sort of stayed away from doing
these group announcements yeah they
haven't
they haven't done any conventions
yeah they're with sony now and so uh
if they did announce it it would
probably more likely be at a state of
play or at sony's conference
tony doesn't do a lot at gamescom so my
guess would be probably state of play
paris and this you're right you're right
and then sony did say they're not going
to have a presence at gamescom it's
going to be
box yeah it's gonna xbox and i think
i've got like one other maybe you'll be
so often embrace yourself again i feel
like gamescom was always more pc stuff
mostly or like development
third party
yeah yeah
so yeah what about you like i mean so i
mean if you think back on what we've had
shadow keep is the last one that stuck
the year
because probably they had to basically
beyond light was a 14 month cycle
because we had the september push to
november is that almost 15 months it was
september october so it was two years
october november i think it was november
i think it was november yeah because
that was 14 months then witch queen
pushed that three months out because we
get the six month season so that was a
15 month cycle yeah which queen have
felt forever jesus together i mean
that's
really long oh yeah you guys those you
guys want all the content at once then
you're okay with the drought right
yeah like be careful what everybody
wishes for be like oh we want the big
expansions and it's like no you don't
yeah not anymore we just want more
cosmic horses i do
try if you push it back you're done with
seasonal model you're done with tune in
next
seasonal model week yeah just just give
me an annual release i'll review it and
then i won't think about it for a year
okay well anyway so 15
sorry i just want to clarify the problem
with the activision model in my
uh opinion was not a
uh annual release it was the annual
releases with like expansions in between
they were doing two expansions they
would just release which was crazy
uh and yeah there was just a lot going
on with that and i feel like annual
release is possible i just assumed that
they wouldn't hit it because of it and
remote work and all the other stuff that
they got going on they just got acquired
i'm sure that that's changing some
things for them so i don't know but i'm
skeptical but this is a comforting sign
that they announced it so early so so go
ahead
uh anyway so if you take eve even if you
take 15 months and that's why i wanted
to kind of bring up like iron banner
season of the risen uh solstice
not bug free
just i mean
are you implying no i'm just saying i
don't want to see them try and squeeze
it into 12 months
i don't want to see them go february to
february
so it's like my expectation
is if we can get about the same as last
time for about a 15-month cycle it's
going to fall in may of 2023.
now
depending on when dates start dropping
as we get closer to the end of 2022
we're going to start to see dates for
red fall or starfield for forza
motorsport for
lots of games that 2023 is now stacked
with that have been like pushed just
over the lines four spokens now in
january as well like true there's a lot
that's going to be let's be honest
though e
i know where you're going no i'm knowing
i'll let you let me let you finish and
then i'll well it's like all i'm just
saying is like i don't know for one i
don't think if they
i don't think they should try and
squeeze it into a year because proof of
the past year has shown us that
they need time to work out some bugs and
polish and things like that so if they
try and do it in a shorter window than
they've done in the past few years
i feel like we would get
a rushed piece of content it would i
think it would feel rushed we would find
like the rough edges on a lot of things
so i think the 15-month window puts it
into
may i also think if you look at the way
this year and things launched which were
it was stacked fairly early but it seems
like people want to get like now that we
had like the may window was not as big
of a time
may actually work
fairly well as a quieter window as
opposed to now like january february
march does seem like a pretty popular
window because
yep destiny was like yeah three days
away from god of war and two days away
from horizon and i was like oh my god
now i don't know where things are gonna
fall again but may doesn't feel like
it's like hey we just had to push it
into 2023
okay but there's probably like five
months gives a lot of times for things
things to come out
and i feel like may is never like a
crazy busy time almost get into the
summer movies are starting to go out i
feel like it's going to give them a lot
of space
and also they probably need the
development time for this big of an
expansion same teams on the campaign
that was on which queen we want we have
a bar for which we can campaign now oh
yeah
we don't want to go down from there we
got to get the raid we've got a season
to go with it and stuff like that
and if it took them that long to get
which queen made i feel like it's going
to take at least a similar amount of
time so
what you what are you preaching
take 15 months
release it in may and then take another
15 months and release the final shape on
the 10th anniversary of destiny
september
okay there you go okay that's actually a
pretty good idea i still believe it is
look all i was going to say is just that
um you went down a different path i'm
going to let you finish
because i was going to say something
else but um
no i get you on
quality right i get you on on bug
they're definitely lately
you know it's it's it's become an issue
you know saying that i'm starting to see
some patterns of of things you know
breaking and stuff like that i don't
know what's going on is it just a
transitionary thing we know they're
hiring we know they got a lot of things
going on
but um
you know where the only point i wanted
to make was just that in reference to
whenever it releases
i'm not truly worried about 2023 because
listen 2023 is going to be massive for
games
there's so many games coming out so many
things that missed this year coming out
next year and then 2023 got its own
lineup of games that was already
scheduled it's gonna be crazy
one thing destiny is proof
it don't it don't move it don't shake it
unfold i mean i get that
pretty much no games do that
right developers don't don't just not
release their game when it's ready
because of other i will say before
spoken as the only one recently in their
press release that has actually sounded
like they did
that's the only one normally not
yeah normally not some people
say i think i think the the key word and
what i said was a game that's ready
it doesn't get released
if you're already nervous about your
game then yeah you can you can work
around other people but that's a
different thing because
which queen was what was what was
officially 22nd
elden ring
three days later
right then i forgot about that he didn't
care about what they was doing
and let's be honest we talking that's
because it's it's own lane right it's
it's like launching the racing game with
the you know whatever it's just it's own
genre so it's generally not going to
conflict the only time they need to
worry is when and i'm not saying you're
saying that i'm just saying like it's
like okay
let's say outriders and warframes like
yo we coming out next to lightfall too
you know then it's like oh okay yeah i
might even yeah soul frame and outriders
to come out on the same week
my argument to that would be that there
are very few people who have the stomach
for two life surgeries exactly and those
people are called paul tassie and
they're the only ones with that problem
okay they're the only ones who face this
problem shut up
you're right and those are the only
times where like i feel like the destiny
community because listen that's the
community gonna do what the destiny
community does and when that witch queen
every even you i know how much you care
about elder ring you're like damn i'm
gonna have to get witch queen and it's
raid done
bro you're talking about no no i'm
talking about um e i'm talking about e
like e was like damn
horizon forbidden what fell under the
rope for you because
trust me i know
yeah to be fair and you know he and i
did not have a choice to do that i had i
had to review him had to make clothes
there's no way i'm like oh what are you
going to play the one that my entire
channel is based around and then i
actually make money off of no i'm going
to go have fun in eldering and not make
content
of course not that was like literally
one of my
most profitable months i've ever had was
literally which queen i'm like
amazing that's like you that's like you
saying like oh wow travis you must
really like work you always choose it
over vacation and i'm like well it's not
a new vacation all you know
yeah
i feel you i feel you it's just one of
those things i know what happens with it
when it comes around it's just funny but
not with you on the um you know pushing
for the highest quality of course of
course when the highest quality release
that we they could possibly do take as
much time as you need but it's an
extremely positive sign that they're out
here doing
reviews and dates of of what's coming
and i'm like okay so that's the question
what do you think we get in august do
you think we get a 2023 do you think we
get a spring 2023 do you think we get a
may 2023 how
fi how narrowed down do we get in august
in terms of whether they're actually
going to tell us right yeah do you think
they're going to say next year no
kidding
season month like how how finite do you
think we're going to get in august of
this year when it's like nine months
away is it just common now for for devs
to say like a season or like a quarter
right like are they saying are they
going to say like i mean fall
like yeah
yeah we're going to get like a day yeah
i mean i've seen all of it
destiny doesn't do that though they do
dates
yeah they do do dates that's true yeah
they do dates and then they just delay
it so my guess would be that
we get a very similar amount of content
to what we got when they reveal the
witch queen probably a cinematic trailer
that establishes the premise of what's
going to happen in the expansion and
then we get a date and that date is
subject to move as it always is
do you think they're going to be
do you think they're going to be
conservative with the data do you think
they're going to be aggressive you think
they're going to be like hey we're gonna
get out to you in a year and then like
later on they push it or you think
they're just gonna be like yep
i was like i wanna know what you think
they're gonna say in may i wanna know
what do you think is gonna be on that
screen at the end of that trailer in
august
it's going to be a spooky alien probably
mm-hmm
and then they've got like fog heads
coming out like that february
february i think they'll give the
february march date and then and then
delay it we'll kick it maybe i guess
yeah i'm probably i'll probably go on
march one march give a couple months
february was witch queen
give them march and then
i'll tell you right now that trailer
gonna hit
that trailer
thing is because
he's in the cut he's been in the cut for
a while now we know he is
so
what
what stakes will be raised and the
question is see what i loved about witch
queen
was just to lead up with like the osiris
betrayal thing i mean you know the
double dagger thing oh such risks you
know
it did like you had you know she was
just conniving right
and on the actor the action
dude
wilson yeah
she was in mad tv when i was a kid like
i've loved that show so yes bro i'm with
you same thing and it's like wait she
was the sec like whatever sister and
fall in order
yeah no she was one of the sisters she
was the the lady who brought you on to
the ship
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay that makes
sense she's like
she's like the i'm out of touch with the
force
they gotta
but they gotta do something
really get the preorder
then we go oh yo
it's on now like okay
but then remember like
so here's the balance of the marketing
and i know you're going to say it but
you know keep playing how's that going
for you keep playing
shout out real quick to mri gamer great
show gems love hearing eric and cog's
expert opinions and even travis's casual
perspective of destiny 2 on the show
mri throwing some heat out there and
then travis fired back it's all love
it's all good
um
no i wanted to ask you guys though
season of the lost
knowing what's coming in which queen
did that take some of the weight out of
season of the lost
no
no i don't think so
i'm asking cog because he's now rocking
he's like no i'm asking all of them for
me i'm here to hear you complain so i
actually i actually think it helped you
we talked about this that like because
we knew how it was going to end it made
each week during season the losses
anticipation like we were just we were
waiting for the other shoe to drop so i
think there's a right way to do it but i
think in the the question you ask the
answer is no absolutely i just want to
know how much they go spoiled to piss
you off
i want them to show these
i want us i want them to show us the end
of the final shape during the trailer
you know on in august
now travis is just being i mean
yeah no it's like i honestly and i think
and that's why i kind of wanted to ask
you guys like you can have your
expectations of what i want
but
i think that the fact that witch queen
had such a twist
we never saw the cliff scene come in we
never expected well yeah we never
expected the witness we never expected
those major points
uh by the way uh since i'm thinking
about major points in the story have you
done the parasite quest
yeah
uh i need a group chat
to shame cognito right now um everybody
i need everybody to go on twitter and
tag cognito hashtag do the worm quest
and then we'll come back
do the worm quest please tag cognito i
need everybody to do that
yeah there's a thing
there's a diggity there's a thing it's
the one thing yeah
yeah i forgot about that i forgot that
there was even story in that like it
seemed like such a weird place to put it
i just
argued about worms and guns
mri gamer
mri gamer this these are your experts
[Laughter]
experts right okay just make sure just
make sure these are there oh gk balance
is like hashtag do the work
i mean but i like that
he talks to people that got the iron
lord title and you know some person is
deficient and he's got to teach the
people that have it you know the people
that they are
to do
you know what the title means is you
were patient enough to grind your
eyeballs yeah minimize it now the person
that was in the 11th hour tweeting
you think i wanted to be doing that
exactly exactly
hey for the record i've been consistent
on this topic when i see a title over
someone's set head it makes me sad for
them so
i
please do not look at my multiple gilded
dredren
no don't worry i've i've met teddy
you're safe yeah you're fine we have we
have we have a friend who's way worse
than all of us i always was like
in the last week of the season that's
the idea is like as you said they have
to in lightfall i do expect a trailer i
don't expect just like lightfall date
nothing i do expect them to talk about
this because like they're probably going
to do like art 3.0 here's the raid
here's the season that's launching today
you'll see it an hour they don't need to
give us everything we're going to see it
in like an hour but for lightfall i
don't know if we're going to get a full
vidoc we might because it's kind of
around that time
um hashtag cog for crocs
that's a shout out to necromancer for
the five dollar super chat um
evil cry i expect the trailer potential
vidoc situation showcase is big they
won't do d2 showcase without like
you know 15 17 minute videos and the
seasonal trailer is gonna be like a
couple minutes of that so vidoc maybe
luke smith is coming out talking about a
tv show they're working on to travis's
chagrin maybe we get the
maybe we get the mobile game coming out
who knows
the movie yeah
but the one
don't forget about the album no don't
forget about the hot single not single
yeah yeah let's go no but it's so late
sorry okay no for say
trailer we got do you think we hear do
you think we hear about the new subclass
yeah your name
oh well i feel like that's the thing
right that's the thing that's gonna be
gotta be in the next one
and it's gotta be pushing towards that
because
i mean have they said they were going to
do three darkness classes
i don't think that was specifically said
but if if you look at the format of the
way they have their weapon system it is
heavily important
it was like in d1 how it looked like
there was going to be more pips in the
in the subclass selector from like date
one there's like clues that it's gonna
be there's like a symmetry to it there's
like a
so i'm i feel like that's the thing that
is the thing they're gonna tease in the
next one it's like we're gonna get a
little bit more story but it isn't the
final story because they've told us that
there is a final story yeah but we're
gonna get we're gonna get another good
piece of progress and i feel like it
they've got to throw down another
subclass and it's got to be
you know the big piece and uh
did they
when they and did this like last summer
did they open pre-orders at that time as
well was it like here's a date and
here's pre-orders or was it like
here's a yeah
and then pre-orders came a little
because i feel like i ended up getting
like a discounted deal pretty early on
they put the the the hive ghost out
there remember they was like i have cars
yeah i got those
with the knobs on the the little radio
thing that was part of the special oh
yeah bro they this is a marketing blitz
about to happen we bout to lose a
hundred and fifty dollars early
yeah yeah they bought the hammer for a
god of war so
the special edition comes with a uh
a signed copy of the um the script the
full script for lightfall and the
expansion that happens after
yeah you're messy you messy right now
like it's they go for the photo of your
your favorite character that dies and uh
the collector's edition box is shaped
like a tombstone
um
look i think yeah i think it's it's
going to be a big blitz i think they'll
it'll be a major story beat reveal
with something really cataclysmic that
we go okay the stakes are so high that
he's here and he's enacting some plan
and then i do
i'm with res i think
because part of the expansion is always
something transformative that's going to
happen in the game gameplay wise right
so they sold us craft we're like oh
craft
what's the big system change that was
going to be my next question
right so there's going to be i've got it
don't you i want a serious answer
i have a serious answer i don't believe
you
he's the he's the witness he's all about
collecting things i think he's gonna
vault the game i think he's just gonna
you son of a
put it all on his pyramid museum that's
it pull up there
could you imagine like if we logged in
the director just had a pyramid and you
had to go in and unlock strikes and you
had to like pull crucible out of there
and you're like unlocked that's what the
pyramids are the pure the pyramids are
dcv they that's that's what they're
ridiculous
you guys
it would work though law wise what
you're saying is fire like because they
could be yo the parent [ __ ] took all
our stuff
yeah they took mars they took
me now you don't got nothing you got to
earn it back
the whole journey and she's in amanda's
holiday like they're gone we have them
in the pyramids that's it right but yeah
i think i think it's gonna be like i
said story beat major witness stuff
um gameplay changing aspect um in the
game that i don't know but i'm leaning
with the extra thing will be a subclass
i think it's time i think the rumors
were what that we were supposed to
potentially get the poison subclass for
which he was
[Music]
even when you look at certain weapon
classes and stuff like that like when
you look at what's the osteo striga and
stuff like that like they're meaning
oh i have one spoiler shout out to tk
omar and chat tess everest will survive
oh
against uh the witness slash the
darkness is you have to um power up a
giant weapon by spending enough silver
you have to it's a silver powered weapon
oh no it's a community silver powered
weapon the community gold
silver the community has suspended
you know what guardians you guys didn't
reach your goal
yeah they have instead of like the blood
drive fundraiser amount it's the silver
fundraiser amount to fire the big game
ending gun there you go yeah bungie if
you guys are listening this we're just
giving you a hard time but yeah this is
just
please also please don't these are not
good ideas don't use it
please don't listen to travis do not
listen to travis the witness's only
weakness is unfettered late stage
capitalism that's really he's not for it
yeah that's why he hates our friends
yeah he's talking about the endgame you
have no more pieces to move
i've taken all that
there it is there it is we got our
answer right there saying guys it's a
great idea
yeah somewhere
that one's i mean subclass yeah i think
we have to at some point because they've
mentioned they didn't quite make it then
we got all the 3.0
some subclass situation has to be there
i feel like there's going to be i feel
like what they did with which hoon was
really cool they're like hey you have
high guardians this is a huge focus the
way they spun the story in the end i was
like
that was really well done i want another
one of those called campaign goals
campaign has to be fire like
i mean
legendary campaign solo legendary camp
solo's the better way to go apparently
uh it was easier yeah it really was
because i went back with three players
trying to do like uh sabathune i was
like this is there's a lot of damage you
gotta do
um
but like the campaign will be fun we're
to get a new destination we've been told
we always get a new destination
with an expansion it is a full
destination
um full destination subclass
now theoretically we've talked about
this season 19 has that
hopeful
pvp
something going on we don't have any
idea to what level
but in season 19 there might be some
work in these survival playlists
though because they'll have ark out and
they'll have chance to like within
stasis is out and all the 3.0s are out
then you balance after that right i feel
like that makes sense so yeah season 19
is the pvp season it's a six month
season they get more time to work on it
they work on that one pvp is a little
better going into lightfall
um lightfold we might get a map or two
maybe probably need one or a couple of
those
um
well you gotta wonder if they're gonna
stick
like trials and banner where they're at
right is like are they going to say like
this is the iteration we've made and
this is what we want to leave in the
game
or are those going to evolve continually
too because it almost seems like
switching to rift
and like changing the vendor stuff they
kind of have it like we're supposed to
get like that's what we're supposed to
at least one more game mode i think this
year right because we were promised rift
was coming and then two other game modes
and i don't think we've seen
i don't think we've seen
all of the game modes they did at one
point and now granted i don't know if
it's going to happen
but now granted i don't know if it like
zone control is going to be one of them
i think it could because they've talked
about that
and then
maybe one other one so we'll have to say
whatever what was kill confirmed called
in destiny
supremacy yeah yeah
like i mean
it also could be kind of just made me
think it could be that just they shift
one of the modes to like a new playlist
or something or one of the playlists
like a new mode you know what i mean
like the way they switch banner to rift
it could just be like yeah we're gonna
get in another new play like another new
mode but it's just that trials is gonna
become
control
yeah you know as long as your act as
long as you're open to adding new modes
bungie might i recommend
um
competitive
no i want to see a ladder ranked that's
what i want to see it's like i want our
ladder to play with so bad
just like i want to know that i'm in
bronze and if that's where i'm supposed
to stay fine but like i want to know
if i'm improving like pull me out of
this and say i'm in
like i would i don't want to get into it
oh yeah
we've said it numerous times now you're
you're in good company you're talking
you're in good company you're preaching
my preach
i will say like the
yeah the one big system i would want
you know what it is
armor
3.0 now granted i have no idea what that
is like you guys can always ask but
i don't i still i don't know what that
looks like in the game that's why i was
like i could ask for it but i i don't
even know what that is at this point
but
someone reminded me just a couple days
ago what the old armor
like felt like where you had to like
hope that you had like a
something that did the kind of like yeah
helmet for hand cannons you're like now
it's just mods yeah i'm just like you
know what
this is very good compared to that and
that's sometimes hard to do when you
find yourself doing that kind of
comparative
sort of thing it's like you're like
you're saying you don't know what armor
3.0 could be but it is still bad
compared to what other games do it it's
bad for compared to the truth
even out writer's world slayer which is
on its second
just fantastic stuff it its armor system
is like it makes just
like
yeah yeah i mean it is like it's the
last thing we got armor crafting we've
got
subclass 3.0s now i mean this new red
set it's like it's the last thing to
really be
customizable granted we do have a lot of
mods that kind of customize it but again
that's what i was like i don't
i don't know what it specifically looks
like in my head but i do feel like it is
the the last like piece of the character
puzzle or on the other side
alex
can we get pvp 1.0
please
thank you for the five dollar super chat
alex appreciate
you just did say like you said armor
crafting i know you meant weapon
crafting but i wonder if it was like
crafting like that's yeah you oh okay so
that's what cool because that's what i
was gonna get at is like what if it is
like you completely craft all of your
stuff like you don't you don't build it
from
like oh whatever you
think like you actually build out like
and it's a lot more focused than it is
because like weapon crafting was
actually i would say
one of them sorry my dog it's just
i have three you're fine they're like
you know weapon crafting
complicated is all hell when it first
came out didn't seem like many people
were gonna push forward but like i found
myself pushing for those raid craftables
like right away like i was like ooh this
is like there is a lot of potential here
and there's especially a lot of
potential because they tend to do a
really good job of synergizing within
like the raid stuff you get like the mod
perk the the mods for the raids and
stuff like that like so that excited me
i would love to see them
like somehow get deeper with that that
would be a very cool way to do it that
would be a cool addition
he might have answered it that might be
the way i mean because at the end of the
day like
they brought crafting in for a reason
right and
maybe that's their their way that they
because the way the the mindset is like
okay we know we have an rng based game
but ultimately if we're going to allow
people to craft we want them to have
this quote-unquote investment in the in
the weapon and stay with it this long
time and to unlock these other things
and use another currency to do it so
i don't know if uh crafting armor would
solve their problem though because well
no not necessarily but it does link into
crafting like your whole character right
yeah but the only thing you'd be able to
craft really are the stat points because
the rest are mods that you apply because
that's how they decided they want to do
it and
the problem with that is are the
limitations on the mods themselves based
on slot and overall power usage and all
that stuff and so i don't know if
if crafting is the is the uh
fix all
unless they truly rework the armor
system to to fit into this new model and
whatever that is a completely separate
idea
but it also could be huge right that
could change
entirely you know
yeah
that's what i would want i would want
them to throw out like to me crafting
isn't enough if they keep the same model
i think that they need to yeah i think
it's gonna be a whole model entirely you
need to add some bonuses
that bonuses
please
i was thinking exactly of crafting
inside like wow or final fantasy like
where you get you're building something
to be like very specific like if you're
crafting a set that is meant to be a set
that's for doing something and they kind
of have that like with the raids if you
if you play them enough and you're
actually looking to strategize and like
play the masters and stuff you have to
go deep into making sure you have like
okay i unlocked all the mods and i know
how i'm setting this thing up so like if
that was something that was able to be
more global that was say
inherent to like my character after i
had spent time investing in it like i
would see that as like a win
in terms of however they they've passed
me to like doing that whether they call
it crafting and i gotta go build it out
a certain way or whether i gotta go
collect them somewhere or something like
if it if it ends with okay we're not
going to keep cycling you through this
thing but you will have an identity that
you will have built into your character
or something like that could be because
destiny hasn't ever
truly had that it's had like identity in
terms of like very specific builds but
then again it also is cool because it's
so open-ended
and you can build so many different
things in it and they've given us with
that with the like the classes right
being able to choose everything instead
of just picking like three diamonds it's
like it's it's beco each of those things
has become more like customizable to
like the individual player over time so
maybe that's the route
well they also do i mean crafting
origin traits
a lot of the weapon stuff we have had
this year
is a soft sunsetting situation because
sun setting didn't stick
should have but that's a whole different
thing um
so
again as res mentioned very early on
with regards to solstice why does he
have any reason to play these activities
for
armor sets when he has three or four
sets you even have the easy ability now
it's like one upgrade module or
something to switch between arc and
solar whenever you need i do that a lot
more now just for like for raids or end
game stuff where it's like oh this
wasn't gonna work but i can actually and
i don't have to spend like hours and
hours i can just go
it's like so like it's the last way for
them to soft sunset
all the crazy people who have grinded
out their perfect armor it's the way for
them to soft sunset armor and make give
you a reason to go get new stuff
that's why again i don't know what set
they build but i do feel like it is the
final
piece that needs that kind of that level
of
because right now being as armor is not
sunset you have your sets you're good
you just switch and change mods and now
the colors are even easier they need a
reason for you to want to care about
armor because the longer the stuff goes
on the less and less i care about armor
even in this i'm like cool i got a 67
but i'm like it's fine
half the time i don't even really care
like you care about one stat you play
with the rest unless you're just trying
to be like the optimal trials player
than me
you've got so many tools to like sort it
later that it's just like immediately
like all
i know there's probably something i
should think about here but i'm just
going to throw here i'll think about
later you know like just toss it away
and look at it with the with a tool
later or something
so yeah theoretically destination
obviously we would get a raid possibly a
subclass possibly the major system
change
those are the four things that i think
i'd like to see in august as even if
they're just even like
teasing weapon crafting just tease the
other piece that's just like same idea
just let us know that like in the back
let us start spinning our wheels because
that's what we're going to do for about
nine months
but yeah we got about a month till that
one drops until the new season month
till final question
uh
rez what raid do you want to see in uh
next season
well um
you get one answer not three all right
oh it's like
i i would like it to be um wrath because
i never did wrath
um that's fair that's kind of a wish
answer no i mean it's not about it
choice
um i have a feeling though it's going to
be uh taken king uh it's gonna be black
king's fall
yeah i feel like it's gonna be
kingsville
doggy what do you want
king rath
i want savithun to be right two lies two
truths
yeah let's go
it's time
travis which one do you want fire of
stars
welcome garden
you want to run around with the greed
mechanic
yeah he wants to know he wants to like
before deep stone go into space there
was spire stars going to space i love
sparrow i love cb grey but when they
said that rape i almost walked off my
own [ __ ]
yeah we did that was crazy
that was unhappy behavior
yeah
y'all destiny is in question when i
heard that it told me how exciting i was
for that oh my god
to each his own yeah i think that they
could stay in the vault forever he could
the witness could keep that one well
next week
because here's my here's my argument for
spire of stars
because that if they re-release fire up
stars
then when
the witness comes and destroys our solar
system we'll feel like it was justified
and i feel like that will help us
empathize a little bit more with the
witness you know it kind of builds
builds a little character development
for him
you know makes us feel for him a little
bit it's like yeah we kind of had this
coming
anyway he allowed this to exist next
week we're actually supposed to figure
out the launch
time of the new raid i kind of doubt
they're going to tell us which raid
until the 23rd
i don't think because some people are
like oh we're going to figure out the
raid next like next week i'm like i
think we're just going to get the day of
the raid not the not the raid my guess
because oh leona posted something about
saying like hey uh next week stay tuned
for at least a certain date not the big
big date but a certain date
because the the raid is just for the
next season right yes
yeah
raid
solid yep arc 3.0 raid story quest for
seven weeks yep i'm like that that's
next season we know the vibes yep yeah
cool well that is about all we got
ladies and gentlemen thank you chat you
guys have been on fire
but a lot of shots go in many different
directions if you enjoyed the show make
sure you guys do drop a like on this one
if you heard it on audio also please
leave us a positive review likes or
however the platform you're listening
you can review us
and please make sure you follow like
subscribe to all these wonderful people
go
check out all of travis's reviews please
go look at the xenoblade review next
week and give it a
positive comment in between the mess of
storm that's going to be in the comments
down below
uh
comments exist
if you guys are not listening to
defining duke if you guys actually don't
check out the last hand media
crossover between defining duke and
sacred symbols go check that one out
it's funny to see like xbox get crapped
on and playstation get crapped on just
as equally so that was a nice balance of
both and then of course
this man up here in the corner please go
check this artist out please go apply a
piece of cool art very stylized love
like it's they literally are bleeding
with style it's very very cool but at
this point
you said that earlier that's
specifically right uh like actually
specifically right
i'd bear a certain word choice for a
reason so yeah glad it worked out um but
yeah at this point the platform is yours
rez to tell people where to find you
where to support you where to check out
all of the things that you do
yeah i'm on uh the internet i've you've
probably heard of it it's great
series of a lot of tubes that are
connected together uh you can find it at
a resolution
it is very tubular uh yeah so
irresolute.com and uh twitter i'm at a
resolute that's i-r-r-e-z-o-l-u-t
uh if i say it in nato fanatic my amazon
thing will hear me
but
um yeah that's where i am i'm serially
online and have been since about 1999.
so you'll find me
coming through pulling up
a lot of fun man this was a good show
love the gaming history love the stories
it was good good good go support the
work man guys got some great paintings
out there i might have to get that red
drake's might have to get that little
let's let's do a couple things you got
up in there i need some more syrian
things no i just got it from you know
what i like to hunt so i just need a
little bit more osiris-like stuff
and i take all sorts of stuff if you
have ideas like i'm happy to have pieces
for people
and yeah so just hit me up um i'm gonna
be
for about a week and then i'll be back
online again uh when i get back from
doing some family stuff down in florida
uh but also
[ __ ] just shout out hit up guardians
mental health like if if you have
folks that you want to support in the
gaming industry it's
they're a rare group right like there's
there's a lot of people that are trying
to do good and i feel like a lot of
times we're trying to do good on the
back end of something as a response and
guardians is trying to get in there and
help people like now and during and
after comes after but like getting in
and doing some support it's it's great
and even just seeing people like take it
seriously take the mental health of like
the gaming community seriously because
you know we need it we need something
because it's been languishing so they do
great work they're at guardians mh on
twitter
guardiansmh.org on the internet
um they're fantastic and i i always
appreciate how
kind and supportive joe and everybody
can be even when i'm a crazy messed up
person on the internet being loud about
things that get people angry but like
they do a really good job and they're
very supportive and very very
understanding and they're doing it for
as many people as they possibly can
they're constantly doing what they can
for for others out there so go support
them as well
for sure salute to that man that's super
important especially the proactive piece
so do you involve yourself with that and
bungie and everybody getting behind it
really important they've been great to
us they've been amazing the fact that
they had they had our you know just to
like take another quick second like they
had our mental health professionals from
our team actually help them curate their
resources right
they got some help from some other
groups too but like they they went to uh
jean-luc dr goku and tap zap matt they
went to them like right away and they
were able to give them a huge amount of
support and
they have in turn given guardians a ton
of support too so it's been really great
to work with a little keep doing the
thing man i love to hear it love to see
it well as we're running a little bit
long short outros from my co-host here
real quick travis look for that
xenoblade casino blade see if i can say
it right xenoblade review coming yeah
check out my reviews my previews and
ign.com follow me on tiger travis if you
have a thirst for death uh and uh yeah
other than that i'll see you next week
and
stay frosty or whatever
i believe the word is mcclunky but
anyways we broke trash
damn it
that bad tired
no i need to write my review i'm looking
at the clock going i'm running out of
time so yeah yeah we got to get a
business review we got to give you
something
the lord's day our lord podcast please
salute shout out to finally duke said
maddie some love he heard his back so
i'll be i'd host it this week come check
out me rand outdoor and mr ben smith
talk about what's going on in xbox and
uh yeah man that's pretty much oh lord
to give me that go check out some
articles and you'll see some stuff
you got some cool people over there as
for me it's about this everywhere uh if
you want to support me thing to watch
right now watch my solstice video um
sponsored video so it just definitely
helps me out
everybody thank you chat thank you of
course big shout out pleasure to have
you on here uh irresolute appreciate the
chat
very easy discussion and fun times
tonight with everybody so thank you all
very much for episode number two oh
seven wow uh next week as the cross is
on so don't miss it whoa
ross you gotta aztec ross oh this is
magical
has to cross
cross is great i'm gonna be a nice guy i
was just messing around
uh so don't miss next week live show and
other than that thank you guys for
episode 207 it has been
the last word